Hey, good morning everybody. How's everybody doing? Real good. What a nice sleep. What a yeah. Will, you were snoring a little bit last night. I had to turn you over a couple of times. I know. Yes, and I had no covers on me. That was weird. No, you didn't.
嘿，大家早上好。大家最近怎么样？挺好的。睡得真香啊。对啊。威尔，昨晚你打呼噜了。我不得不帮你翻了几次身。我知道。是的，而且我身上没盖被子。那太奇怪了。不，你盖了。
Yeah. But I love that extra super-sized Charlie and the Chocolate Factory bed we got, huh? Hey, be honest. What was the camera for? Because I noticed a camera this morning when I woke up. That was my bad. That was my bad. I forgot to take it down. Okay.
对。但我很喜欢我们买的那张查理和巧克力工厂超大号床，对吧？嘿，说实话。那个摄像头是干什么用的？因为我今天早上醒来时注意到了一个摄像头。那是我的错。那是我的错。我忘了把它拿下来。好吧。
Anyway, let's do a podcast. Welcome to Smartless. Yeah. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
不管怎样，我们开始播客吧。欢迎收听 Smartless。对。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. How's everybody doing? I'm great. I haven't even had a chance to open up my breakfast bar. Hello, ASMR. This is Papa Steve's No Junk Raw Protein Bars, which I'm real keen on, and my address you can find in the chat. Jesus. Okay, have you guys had your breakfast yet?
Less。大家过得怎么样？我很好。我甚至还没来得及打开我的早餐能量棒。哈喽，ASMR。这是“史蒂夫老爹”无添加纯天然蛋白棒，我非常喜欢，我的地址你们可以在聊天区找到。天哪。好吧，你们大家吃过早餐了吗？
I have. I have not. What did you have, Willie? I had one cup of oatmeal made with water, and some berries. Do they let you out for an hour of exercise each day? Yeah, yeah. I had a few berries with it,
我吃了。我还没吃。你吃了什么，威利？我吃了一杯用水泡的燕麦片，还有一些浆果。他们每天放你出来锻炼一个小时吗？对，对。我在里面加了一些浆果，
and then a drizzle of maple syrup, pure maple syrup for taste. I love to drizzle ever again. Yeah, and then I had five scrambled eggs. Jesus, my chest hurts. Five eggs? Well, your chest should have hurt, it's not bad for your chest.
然后淋上枫糖浆，纯正的枫糖浆来调味。我最喜欢淋……再次。对，然后我吃了五个炒鸡蛋。天哪，我胸口疼。五个鸡蛋？好吧，你胸口疼是应该的，这可对你的胸口没好处。
You know, I think there was one report that said that eggs are not cholesterol problems anymore, and I love that report as much as you do, but I'd love to hear a second. My doctor told me that. So my- This is the guy you found online? Put it this way.
你知道，我记得有一份报告说鸡蛋不再会导致胆固醇问题了，我像你一样喜欢那篇报道，但我很想听听第二份报告。我的医生是这么告诉我的。所以我的——这就是你在网上找到的那个人？这么说吧。
What's your cholesterol and what's mine? And you're the one who like eats all this shit and what's yours and what's mine? My cholesterol is horrendous. Yeah, mine is too. It's in my family. Yeah. Mine's 90.
你的胆固醇是多少，我的又是多少？而且你才是那个吃所有这些垃圾食品的人，你的和我的分别是多少？我的胆固醇糟透了。对，我的也是。这是家族遗传。对。我的才90。
I will tell you, I just had one of those full body scans. Yeah. And- No brain? Yeah. Yeah, yeah, but I will tell you I just had one of those full body scans. Yeah, and No brain. Yeah And completely empty. Sorry, can we talk to you for a second? Yeah It's just one one microchip up there. Oh, yeah They said it's not there's no heart. They just found a box with a picture of a heart in it Well, no, so did you get the results back? Yes, thank you, the results were fine.
我告诉你，我刚做了那种全身扫描。对。而且——没有大脑？对。对，对，但我告诉你我刚做了那种全身扫描。对，而且没有大脑。对，而且完全是空的。抱歉，我们能和你谈一下吗？对，上面只有一个微芯片。哦，对，他们说没有，根本没有心脏，他们只在里面找到了一个画着心脏的箱子。好吧，不，所以你拿到结果了吗？是的，谢谢，结果很好。
Oh good. Everything is fantastic and yeah, I'm very pleased. Cause you never know what those things, you could get the, okay, so your appointment to review, you're going to scan results or is it tomorrow at three o'clock? Okay, so tomorrow at three o'clock I'm going to find out if I've got something I've got gotta worry about the rest of my life. They've got six guys in there like.
哦，太好了。一切都好得不得了，是的，我非常满意。因为你永远不知道那些东西，你可能会拿到——好吧，所以你查看扫描结果的预约是在明天下午三点吗？好吧，所以明天下午三点，我将发现我是否有余生需要担心的毛病。他们里面有六个人，就像是……
They'd actually like to do this in person. The team needs to speak to you. Yeah, that's the word. Hey, Jason, can you clear your schedule for the next four months? And do you have a wife, girlfriend, best friend, something that can maybe drive you? Are you religious at all?
他们其实想当面谈。医疗团队需要和你谈谈。对，就是这样。嘿，杰森，你能腾出接下来四个月的日程吗？你有没有妻子、女朋友、最好的朋友，或者什么能开车送你的人？你信教吗？
Because we got a guy here on standby. No, it's a real, we were talking about it, you and me, Will, the other day, and you were like, well, I don't know, I mean, do you want to know? Do you want, I was like, yeah, I do, if it's good news. And thank God it was good, so. That's good. Did you get the, Sean, did you get the shingles vaccine?
因为我们这有个随时待命的神父。不，真的，我们前几天在聊这个，你和我，威尔，当时你说，嗯，我不知道，我是说，你想知道吗？你想——我说，对，我想知道，如果是好消息的话。谢天谢地，结果是好的，所以。那很好。肖恩，你打过带状疱疹疫苗了吗？
I did. I did. Yeah. Yeah. Did you, Willie? I have not. Okay. You have to, you must. Do you, Willie? I have not. Okay. You have to, you must. Now what is it, if you've had chickenpox, you're susceptible to shingles or vice versa?
我打了。我打了。对。对。你打了没，威利？我没打。好吧。你必须打，你一定得打。你打了没，威利？我没打。好吧。你必须打，你一定得打。话说回来，如果你得过水痘，你是不是就容易得带状疱疹，反之亦然？
It's already living inside you if you had chickenpox, the shingles. So if you haven't had chickenpox, you're good, you don't need the shingles vaccine? I think, I don't know, don't get medical advice from this show. Yeah, exactly, change the channel, everybody. Yeah.
如果你得过水痘，它就已经在你体内存活了，就是带状疱疹。所以如果你没得过水痘，你就没事，不需要打带状疱疹疫苗？我想，我不知道，别从这个节目里听取医疗建议。对，没错，大家都换个频道吧。对。
How often would you say, in any given week, do you have a conversation at least with a doctor? Oh God, on a weekly basis for sure. So it's at least once a week. At least once a week you're interfacing with a doctor via text or call or in person. Why, cause you're concerned or you just wanna stay ahead? I wanna be one of those people
你会说在任何给定的星期里，你大概多久和医生对话一次？哦天哪，每周肯定都有。所以至少一周一次。你至少一周一次通过发短信、打电话或当面与医生交流。为什么，因为你担心还是只是想防患于未然？我想成为那种人——
that catch something before it happens. Right, so you're concerned or you just want to stay ahead of things? I want to be one of those people that catch something before it happens. Right, so you just workshop things that could go wrong with you and what to do to be ready. That's right. You ever thought about just living life and enjoying it? I'll take photos of shit and text him and all that stuff.
能在事情发生之前就把它抓出来的人。对，所以你很担心，或者只是想走在事情的前面？我想成为那种人，能在事情发生之前就把它抓出来的人。对，所以你只是在脑海里彩排那些可能出问题的事，以及该做些什么来做好准备。没错。你有没有想过就过好生活，享受它？我会拍下那些乱七八糟的东西发短信给他之类的。
You could zip into a bubble maybe, and just kind of have Scottie roll you around. From room to room. Yeah, I'm not above it. I'll do that. We were talking about anesthesia, Jason, me and you, I think, at dinner last week. God, I could go for some propofol right now.
也许你可以缩进一个泡泡里，然后让斯科特推着你到处走。从一个房间到另一个房间。对，我不是做不出来。我会这么做的。杰森，我们上周在晚饭时好像在讨论麻醉剂，你和我。天哪，我现在真想来点丙泊酚。
I wouldn't be great. And we were talking about, isn't it fascinating, how did somebody discover anesthesia? Like, who do you test that on? Right, we're gonna bring you as close to death as possible. Getting that just right was probably challenging. That's too much, we lost them.
那感觉一定好极了。我们在讨论，不是很神奇吗，到底是谁发现了麻醉剂？比如说，你拿谁来做实验？对，我们要让你尽可能接近死亡。把那个剂量掌握得刚刚好吧，可能很有挑战性。剂量太大了，我们把人弄死了。
Or too little, you can see them screaming as they amputate the wrist. That's unbelievable. Well, I tell you when you don't want some purple falls, when our guest is performing. Great transition. Because you want to be wide awake Well, I tell you when you don't want some Purple Falls, when our guest is performing... Great transition. Because you want to be wide awake for this person's work.
或者剂量太少，你能看到他们在截肢时疼得尖叫。这太不可思议了。嗯，我告诉你什么时候你不会想要丙泊酚，那就是我们的嘉宾在表演的时候。绝佳的转场。因为你想保持全神贯注……嗯，我告诉你什么时候你不会想要丙泊酚，那就是我们的嘉宾在表演的时候……绝佳的转场。因为对于这个人的作品，你想保持全神贯注。
And I tell you, millions of people have been wide awake watching this guy. He's been... I'm going to say this. He's been dazzling people for a long time. David Copperfield. Well, his... David Blaine. I will just say, Jason, you might want to be careful because this person knows a lot of your secrets. Carrot Top.
我告诉你，数百万人看这家伙的作品时都是全神贯注的。他一直……我要这么说。长久以来，他一直在惊艳着人们。大卫·科波菲尔。嗯，他的……大卫·布莱恩。我只想说，杰森，你可能得小心点，因为这个人知道你很多秘密。胡萝卜头。
Uh-oh. Okay? This person knows... Papa? This person knows a lot of the stuff that you've... Papa-pa-pa-pa-pa? ...been up to, especially recently, because this person is somebody who has been
哦，不。好吧？这个人知道……爸爸？这个人知道很多你……爸爸爸爸爸爸爸爸巴？一直在做的事，特别是最近，因为这个人是那种……
in and out of your world, I'll just say this. This is, again, I always feel like with my guests, it's hard to start naming their credits because you're just gonna, you immediately, you're gonna go, oh yeah, blah, blah, blah. Why is this person my guest then? You say I know this person. You do, and they could be your guests say I know this person. You do.
在你的世界里进进出出的人，我只想这么说。这是，再说一次，我总是觉得我的嘉宾很难开始列举他们的代表作，因为你马上就会说，哦，对了，巴拉巴拉巴拉。那这个人为什么还要当我的嘉宾呢？你说我认识这个人。你的确认识，而且他们可以成为你的嘉宾——你说我认识这个人。你的确认识。
And they could be your guests because I wanted to kind of surprise you. Oh, I want. Because this is somebody who has, this is somebody who's been doing, this is somebody who's been doing the kinds of films that we, Jay, this is the kind of thing for you that fits in like, they're doing the kind of thing
而且他们可以成为你的嘉宾，因为我想给你一个惊喜。哦，我想。因为这是一个，这是一个一直在做……这是一个一直在拍那种电影的人，杰，这就是那种适合你的电影，它们属于那种……
that the taste makers like and like all those kinds of words that you like. See how much disdain he has for that. fits in. Like they're doing the kind of thing that the tastemakers like and like all those kind of words that you like. See how much disdain he has. I know. And, and you know, because there are films in there. This is somebody who's been nominated for Academy Awards, Golden Globe Awards, BAFTA's Olivier Awards.
弄潮儿们喜欢的东西，还有所有那些你喜欢的高级词汇。看他对那些有多不屑。适合。就像它们属于弄潮儿喜欢的东西，还有所有那些你喜欢的高级词汇。看他有多不屑。我知道。而且，你知道，因为里面有电影。这是一个曾获得过奥斯卡奖、金球奖、英国电影学院奖、劳伦斯·奥利弗奖提名的人。
Oh, I don't know anybody who's been on TV. He's done television. He's played the Pope. He's played, he's been in Sherlock Holmes. He's played... He's been in Sherlock Holmes. He's been... He's been... He's been... He's been... He's been a talented mister. Hey, Jude.
哦，我不认识任何上过电视的人。他演过电视剧。他演过教皇。他演过，他演过《福尔摩斯》。他演过……他演过《福尔摩斯》。他演过……他演过……他演过……他演过……他演过才华横溢的……嘿，裘德。
Oh, there he is. And he's... I was wanting to get to you, and he's Jason's co-star and collaborator on Black Rabbit. Is Jude live? Yeah! Good morning, my friend. Good morning. And he should be Good morning, my friend. Hi, Jude. Good morning.
哦，他在这儿。而且他……我正想说到你，他是杰森在《黑兔》中的联合主演和合作者。裘德在吗？对！早啊，我的朋友。早上好。而且他应该——早啊，我的朋友。嗨，裘德。早啊。
And he should be your guest, but I wanted him because I wanted to surprise you, JB, with your guy. Buddy, god damn it, this is great. Guys, get ready to just fall in love and clear out, make room for a new best friend. There's really, Jude, first of all, welcome. There's just nobody Jude, first of all, welcome.
而且他本该是你的嘉宾，但我选他是因为我想给你个惊喜，JB，带上你的好兄弟。老兄，真他妈的棒。伙计们，准备好坠入爱河，腾出空间，为新最好朋友做好准备吧。说真的，裘德，首先，欢迎。真的没有人——裘德，首先，欢迎。
There's just nobody I'm more excited about as a new person in my life, like for the last 10 years in Jude's life. This guy is incredible. Jude, he has been singing your praises since you guys started working together. And I'm not, honestly, I'm not making it up. He cannot speak more highly about,
真的没有人能像我生命中的新人那样让我如此兴奋，就像裘德在我生命中的过去10年里一样。这家伙太不可思议了。裘德，自从你们开始合作以来，他就在对你赞不绝口。我没有，说实话，我不是在编造。他简直对你赞不绝口，
and he has generally disdain for people, as you know. I broke through that. I like five people in the world and there's three on the screen right now. Yeah. I'm going, we finished just a couple of weeks ago and I'm genuinely going through withdrawals. It's been, I mean it was a long shoot,
而且如你所知，他对其他人通常都是不屑一顾的。我打破了这一点。世界上我只喜欢五个人，现在屏幕上有三个。对。我得说，我们几周前刚拍完，我真的正在经历戒断反应。这真是一段——我的意思是这是一次漫长的拍摄，
so you know when it starts to become part of your daily routine and dare I say, you not take it for granted, but you're just, you know, you've been doing it for a few months and it's just, it's what you do every day and man, I'm finding it hard. It's been a bit bumpy coming out. How about you? Yeah, it's like, yeah, on that project it was like waking up in your house each day and just like hanging out with your family And it's just so easy and then you're gone from your family. Do you start to miss them? Yeah, it's it's a very odd part of what we do right because yeah, I was trying to explain this to someone
所以你知道当它开始成为你日常生活的一部分时，我敢说，你并没有把它视为理所当然，而是你只是，你知道的，你已经拍了好几个月，这就是你每天都在做的事，天哪，我发现很难适应。抽离出来有点痛苦。你呢？对，就像是，是的，在这个项目上，就像每天在自己的家里醒来，然后和你的家人一起闲逛，就是那么轻松，然后你离开了你的家人。你开始想念他们吗？对，这是我们所做工作的一个非常奇怪的部分，对吧，因为，是的，我试图向某人解释这一点——
It's like most people Have their first day on a job Like, most people have their first day on a job, like, you know, in their 20s or 30s, and maybe they change their job once, like in their 40s or, we change a job three times a year sometimes, like a whole new group of people. Hi, hello, I'm Jude, nice to meet you. Well, what's so unusual is that Jason has allowed himself
就像大多数人都有他们的第一天工作——就像，大多数人有他们的第一天工作，比如，你知道，在他们的20多岁或30多岁时，也许他们会在40多岁时换一次工作，或者，我们有时一年换三次工作，就像换了一整群新的人。嗨，你好，我是裘德，很高兴认识你。嗯，最不寻常的是，杰森居然允许自己
to get attached to you, because I have heard him describe, and this is true, and I really, this is true. He described recently to somebody, and this really, again, is gonna give you a lot of info about who JB, he talks about how when he starts a job with people, he tells himself not to get too attached because he knows he's not gonna see them again. And so he builds in a distance with people
对你产生依恋，因为我听他描述过——这是真的，我真的，这是真的。他最近向某人描述，这真的，再次强调，会让你对JB这个人有很多了解——他谈到当他和人们开始一份工作时，他会告诉自己不要产生太多的依恋，因为他知道他以后再也见不到他们了。所以他在人际关系中建立了一种距离感，
so he won't get hurt, am I right, JB? Ish, it's not as much of a defense mechanism as just like a practicality. It's like, well, we're going to never see each other again, but there's a necessary bonding that needs to happen to really make the work enjoyable and effective, and so yeah, it's an odd thing we've been developing. I've actually given young actors that advice sometimes
这样他就不会受伤了，我说的对吗，JB？差不多吧，与其说是防御机制，不如说是出于实用性。就像是，好吧，我们以后再也不会见面了，但为了让工作真正变得愉快和高效，必要的黏合是必须的，所以，是的，这是我们一直在发展的一种奇怪的东西。我其实有时会给年轻演员这个建议，
because I remember when I was in my early 20s starting out. You say, don't fall in love with me. You kind of, no, no, you kind of walk away from the film, think I just made 50 best friends and we're gonna see each other every week. And then nothing happens and you feel slightly heartbroken. So you gotta, you know, I'm like, they're not gonna be your best friends,
因为我记得我20岁出头刚出道的时候。你会说，不要爱上我。你会有那种——不，不，你拍完电影离开时会想，我刚刚交了50个最好的朋友，我们以后每周都会见面。然后什么都没发生，你感到有点心碎。所以你得，你知道的，我就会说，他们不会成为你最好的朋友，
you're gonna work together, it's gonna be a great experience. The good news in this business is you actually do have a realistic chance of seeing those people again, though, on another project or. If you're as old as we are. On a podcast, yeah. Now, before we get going, I just, I have seen Jude's film that is coming out to Paris, Yeah, yeah. Now, before we get going, I just,
你们会一起工作，这将是一次美妙的经历。不过这行里的好消息是，在另一个项目上，你确实还有现实的机会再次见到那些人，或者。如果你和我们一样老的话。在播客上，对。好了，在我们开始之前，我只是——我看过裘德即将上映的电影《巴黎》，对，对。好了，在我们开始之前，我只是——
I've seen Jude's film that is coming out, depending on when this airs. It's called The Order. And I've seen it twice in the last three days because they very nicely asked me to introduce it at some screening the other day. This movie, Jude's the lead in it. It's also with Nicholas Holt and Journey Smollett
我看过裘德即将上映的电影，具体上映时间取决于这期节目播出的日期。它叫《火线对决》。我过去三天里看了两遍，因为他们前几天非常客气地邀请我在某场放映活动上做介绍。这部电影，裘德是主演。里面还有尼古拉斯·霍尔特和乔尼·斯莫利特，
and it's directed by Justin Curzell. Guys, if you like a bag of money and a gun and something that is shot like one of those Sidney Lumet films, it's just, this movie is so goddamn good. He plays an FBI agent that is after a white supremacist gang up in the Pacific Northwest. It's a true story, happens back in like the late 70s,
由贾斯汀·库泽尔执导。伙计们，如果你喜欢一袋钱、一把枪，以及那种拍得像西德尼·吕美特电影的作品，这部电影简直太他妈的棒了。他饰演一名FBI特工，正在太平洋西北地区追捕一个白人至上主义帮派。这是一个真实的故事，发生在70年代末、
early 80s, I think, Jude. And it's just badass. Bank robberies and it's just, go see it. It's called The Order, it's fucking great. I can't wait to see that. I obviously haven't seen it and haven't seen the trailer. I saw the one sheet, it looks really,
80年代初左右，我想是的，裘德。这部电影简直酷毙了。抢劫银行，而且真的是，去看吧。它叫《火线对决》，他妈的太棒了。我等不及要看了。我显然还没看过，也没看过预告片。我只看过单页海报，看起来真的很——
just the poster alone looked really cool. And I think that you're like holding a gun in it or something like that. I see it a hundred more times. Talked a little bit, well, just if you can, just because we're on this, to talk a little bit about the order and how it kind of came into your world
仅仅是那张海报本身就看起来很酷。而且我想你手里好像拿着一把枪什么的。我要再看一百遍。稍微聊聊，嗯，只要你行，因为我们正在说这个，稍微聊聊《火线对决》以及它是如何进入你的世界的，
and what it was about it that you're like, oh yeah, this is something I've got to do. Because I don't know necessarily associate you with as a sort of like a gun wrangling, like, you know what I mean? I hadn't played a part like it. And it came my way through my production company. And, you know, it was just one of those. It was so full of potential.
以及吸引你觉得“哦，对，这是我必须拍的东西”的是什么。因为我不一定把你会和那种挥舞着枪的形象联系起来，你知道我的意思吗？我以前没演过这样的角色。它是通过我的制作公司找到我的。而且，你知道，它是那种潜力无限的作品。
It had this incredible true story that I hadn't heard of, an awful lot of people hadn't heard of. It had all this relevance to today and the sort of divisive society that we're living in and that we're seeing around the world. And then, you know, it's also wrapped up in a brilliant cat and mouse thriller kind of genre film. And like Jason said, it's reminded me of those movies,
它有一个我没听说过、绝大多数人也没听说过的不可思议的真实故事。它与当今世界以及我们周围所看到的这种分裂的社会有着极大的关联。然后，你知道，它还包裹在一个精彩的猫鼠游戏惊悚片类型的电影中。就像杰森说的，它让我想起了那些电影，
those kinds of crowd pleases that I used to go see when I was a kid with the great filmmakers of Le Mette and Freekin. And it's funny, isn't it? It's the same with other genres, I suppose. But those kind of movies were at once with Hackman and Newman and people like that in them, so, so popular. And suddenly they, I don't know, they kind of lost their edge maybe. But anyway. No idea why, right?
那些我小时候去看的大师吕美特和弗里金的那些老少咸宜的电影。这很有趣，不是吗？我想其他类型片也是如此。但那些电影里当时有哈克曼、纽曼那样的人，它们非常、非常受欢迎。然后突然间，我不知道，它们可能有点失去了锐气。不过总之。不知道为什么，对吧？
I mean like French connection, like, they don't make those movies anymore. And those used to be like the blockbusters, Why or Dog Day Afternoon? What happened? I think we do, well, I think first of all, I think we do know, and they tried even into the 90s, I was thinking about Ronan, you know,
我是说，就像《法国贩毒网》一样，他们再也不拍那种电影了。而那些过去就像是票房大片，为什么，还有《下午的狗日》？发生什么了？我想我们确实——嗯，我觉得首先，我们确实知道，甚至到了90年代他们还在尝试，我想到了《浪人》，你知道，
that great De Niro, Frankenheimer movie, amazing. Again, trying to extend that idea, even out of sight with Clooney and those guys in- Yeah, or Out of the Furnace, that Christian Bale movie with KCM. All those movies tried, but I think that what happened was, and I think I mentioned this before, we've spent the last at least decade
那部伟大的德尼罗、弗兰克海默的电影，太惊艳了。同样，试图延续那种想法，甚至还有克鲁尼他们的《战略高手》——对，还有《逃出熔炉》，克里斯蒂安·贝尔和凯西·阿弗莱克的电影。所有这些电影都尝试过，但我觉得发生的事情是，我想我之前提到过，我们过去至少十年里
kind of under the tyranny of IP. Yeah, for sure. These films that were made, all the studios owned all this IP, and they're like, how can we squeeze as much as we can out of this IP, whether it's this. I think they're trying to hedge their bet. For people like Sean and Scottie,
某种程度上生活在IP的暴政之下。对，确实如此。这些拍摄的电影，所有的制片厂都拥有所有这些IP，他们想的是，我们怎么能从这个IP中榨取尽可能多的价值，无论是这个。我觉得他们是在对冲风险。对于肖恩和斯科特这样的人来说，
ruined the movie business, because that's what they wanted. Yeah, yeah. I think they're trying to hedge their bet, and they're like, say. I hope they save the planet Lindelor because that's where they, you know. Careful, Jude's got a Star Wars thing coming up.
把电影行业给毁了，因为这就是他们想要的。对，对。我觉得他们是在对冲风险，他们就像是，说。我希望他们能拯救林德霍夫的地球，因为那是他们，你知道的。小心点，裘德接下来还有一部《星球大战》呢。
Star Wars, yes, it's called, yeah, I can't wait. It's called Skeleton Crew, I can't wait. Excluding Jude, I didn't talk about Star Wars, not Jude, Star Wars. Anyway, I think that that is why, but I think you're right, there's an appetite for this kind of thing now. Well, they're assuming they're gonna get a built-in audience
《星球大战》，是的，它叫，是的，我等不及了。它叫《骨干船员》，我等不及了。除了裘德，我没在说《星球大战》，不是说裘德，是《星球大战》。不管怎样，我想这就是原因所在，但我认为你是对的，现在对这种类型的东西很有胃口。嗯，他们假设自己能通过现有的IP
with this existing IP, and so these original things are sort of put on the back burner, but my God, just a pure satisfying experience of going to see a caper, or a thriller, or something with just a true beginning, middle, and end, where you get invested with these characters and there's a sticky plot, and like, why do I need some dude flying around on top of it all? Sean?
获得内置的观众，所以这些原创的东西就被搁置了一旁，但是天哪，去看一部惊险片、惊悚片，或者那种有真正起承转合、让你对这些角色产生投入、情节引人入胜的纯粹满足的体验，到底为什么我需要某个家伙在这一切之上飞来飞去呢？肖恩？
But it goes full circle I'm sure right? I mean people come, they'll always come back to it. It's like vinyl right? Everyone comes back to vinyl. You hope, you hope. Yeah. Hopefully this one will start. You know what, guess what?
但这最终还是会转一圈回来的，我确信，对吧？我是说人们会来的，他们总是会回来的。就像黑胶唱片一样，对吧？每个人都会回到黑胶唱片。但愿如此，但愿如此。对。希望这部能开个好头。你知道吗，你猜怎么着？
It's the same thing with music. My kids listen to all this music that's very good, but it all comes out of electronic interface as opposed to like plugging in an instrument and like you hear a snare drum or you hear a guitar. I mean, I don't even sound like an old fuddy-duddy, but I miss the sound of instruments and music. Hopefully that comes back as well. It'll come back, it'll come back.
音乐也是一样。我的孩子们听的所有这些音乐都非常好，但它们全都是通过电子接口出来的，而不是像插上乐器那样，你能听到小军鼓或吉他的声音。我是说，我听起来甚至不像个老古董，但我怀念乐器和音乐的声音。希望那种东西也能回归。会回来的，会回来的。
I think it does come back. I mean, you're talking a lot about, I suppose, mainstream pop music. There is a huge appetite for, and there's a very thriving indie music, certainly. I'm like such an old school 90s dinosaur indie fan. But that has kind of come back. There's a lot of guitar-driven music out there
我觉得它确实会回来。我是说，你谈论的很多，我猜，是主流流行音乐。确实有巨大的胃口，而且独立音乐非常繁荣，当然。我简直是个老派90年代恐龙级独立音乐迷。但那种音乐已经卷土重来了。外面有很多以吉他为主导的音乐，
that's excellent. A lot of great American bands. Jude, how are you today? Hey, F you, Sean. Sean, go fuck yourself. Hey, do you guys want to hear my impression of Sean and Scotty going to the movies again? Please.
都非常优秀。有很多伟大的美国乐队。裘德，你今天过得怎么样？嘿，去你的，肖恩。肖恩，滚你妈的。嘿，你们想听我再次模仿肖恩和斯科特去看电影吗？请吧。
Whoa, whoa, whoa, I hope that they find, I hope he knows that he's- No, do they go check out two of those? His dad actually came from Skottesgård. Do you know that his dad was in the other and his key came from Scala's core too? Yeah. By the way, we just watched Alien Romulus again.
哇，哇，哇，我希望他们能找到，我希望他知道他——不，他们去看其中两部了吗？他爸爸其实来自斯克特斯高德。你知道他爸爸也演过另一部，他的关键也来自斯克特斯高德吗？对。顺便说一下，我们刚刚又看了一遍《异形：夺命舰》。
Yeah. That mythology is so great. Where does that sit in the order of the alien? Yeah. It comes before the original in the 70s. Oh. Yeah. Oh. Right after, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. Have you watched the original in the 70s. Oh. Yeah. Oh, right after, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
对。那个神话体系太棒了。那在《异形》系列里排在什么位置？对。它发生在70年代的原版之前。哦。对。哦。紧接着，抱歉，抱歉。你最近又看过70年代的原版了吗？哦。对。哦，紧接着，抱歉，抱歉。
Have you watched the original again recently? Yes, it's incredible. And like the design, the design for it, all those people said who was watching it recently and they said, they paused it and zoomed in on a little area in behind, I think, Ian Holm. Yes, yes. And it was basically an old speaker turned inside out,
你最近又看过原版了吗？是的，太不可思议了。就像设计一样，它的设计，所有人都在说，谁最近在看的时候说，他们暂停画面并放大看了一个小区域，就在——我想是伊安·霍姆身后。是的，是的。那基本上是一个把里外翻过来、
upside down and sprayed white or something. What did they do? It's really cool. And in Romulus, the sets they made look like the 80s. I misspoke. It comes after the original. Sorry, in between the original. But anyway. In that early Alien.
上下颠倒并喷成白色的旧扬声器什么的。他们是怎么做到的？真的很酷。而在《夺命舰》中，他们制作的布景看起来就像80年代的。我口误了。它发生在原版之后。抱歉，是在原版之间。但不管怎样。在早期的《异形》中。
Are you a fan? I love Alien, yeah. Yeah, yeah, so good. Where are you right now? Are you in a hotel. Are you a fan? I love Alien, yeah. Yeah, yeah, so good. I think science fiction fans. Where are you right now? Are you hotel, are you home? Where is it? I'm in a hotel in Beverly Hills.
你是影迷吗？我爱《异形》，对。对，对，太棒了。你现在在哪？你是在酒店里。你是影迷吗？我爱《异形》，对。对，对，太棒了。我觉得科幻迷们。你现在在哪？你是在酒店，还是在家？到底在哪？我在比弗利山庄的一家酒店里。
Oh, fantastic. Los Angeles for a while. Promoting and you know. Yeah, he is humping. This guy's got stamina like you cannot believe. He's not going to stop until December. I've heard, again, I don't want to get too much, because we do love the Black Rabbit we wanna talk about.
哦，太棒了。在洛杉矶待一段时间。宣传还有你知道的。对，他可真够拼的。这家伙的耐力简直让你难以置信。他要一直忙到12月。我听说，再次强调，我不想扯得太远，因为我们确实很喜欢《黑兔》，我们想聊聊它。
We're all so excited for Black Rabbit. It was time to talk about that. That's a year from now. I will say, again, this is the highest compliment from JB. He talked about your stamina and your ability to show up on set every day and deliver in every way. I've never seen him so impressed. And as a producer, I've never seen him so impressed.
我们都对《黑兔》兴奋不已。是时候聊聊这个了。那是一年后的事了。我必须说，再次强调，这是来自JB的最高赞赏。他谈到了你的耐力和每天出现在片场并在各个方面都有出色表现的能力。我从未见过他如此印象深刻。作为制片人，我从未见过他如此印象深刻。
I've never seen him so impressed, Jude. Honestly, again, I'm going out of my way here, but it's so true. And the joy, the joy that he got. I need your notes on episode three and four. Take you to turn those around, see if you can do it. Let's not turn this into a work session, okay?
我从未见过他如此印象深刻，裘德。老实说，再次强调，我这里有点多管闲事了，但这千真万确。还有那种快乐，他获得的快乐。我需要你对第三集和第四集的意见。看你能不能搞定，看看能不能扭转局面。我们别把这变成工作会议，好吗？
Let's do it. Let's just house it out now. Okay, well, Jude, let's talk early days as you started as a performer. So we know where you've been and where you are now, but let's flash back to when you were a kid and the first time you said, "'Mom, Dad, I wanna perform',"
干吧。现在就把事情说清楚。好吧，那么，裘德，我们来聊聊你作为表演者刚开始的早期日子。所以我们知道你去过哪里，现在在哪里，但让我们闪回到你还是个孩子的时候，你第一次说：“妈妈，爸爸，我想表演”，
or somebody said, Jude, you need to perform. What was the thing? Was it, were you attracted to it? Did somebody notice it in you? What was the thing? How did it all start? It just sort of occurred because my parents were teachers. This is in the 70s in Southeast London.
或者有人说，裘德，你需要去表演。当时是怎么回事？是因为你被它吸引了吗？还是有人注意到了你的天赋？到底是怎么回事？这一切是怎么开始的？这纯粹是顺理成章地发生的，因为我的父母是老师。那是70年代伦敦东南部。
And they, but they had a passion for theater. So they were members of a local theater company and they were put on plays. And I grew up in a house where I remember there were always, you know, the kitchen was full of people rehearsing and I'd come down and half our furniture would be gone because they'd be using it on a set in the play that they were putting on.
而且他们对戏剧有着强烈的热情。所以他们是当地一家剧团的成员，他们会排演戏剧。我在一个这样的家庭里长大，我记得总是有，你知道的，厨房里挤满了人在排练，当我走下来时，我们的一半家具都不见了，因为他们在排演的戏剧的布景里要用它们。
So it was just a big, I just remember loving watching adults rehearse and goof about. It looked like it was a dialogue, it was a language that made sense to me, and I felt very comfortable in it. So really, honestly, it was like a kind of, what's the right word, segway, as opposed to a kind of decision.
所以这只是一个宏大的，我只记得我非常喜欢看成年人排练和胡闹。这看起来像是一种对话，是一种我能理解的语言，我在其中感到非常舒适。所以真的，老实说，这就像是一种，什么才是正确的词，衔接，而不是某种决定。
I got involved the older I got and did plays, and I joined a company as a kid. Brothers and sisters? I had a big sister who, she performed too, but she's a painter. I thought that was the name of the theater company. I thought Jason was like, Brothers and Sisters Theater Company.
随着我年龄越来越大，我参与进去了，演了戏剧，我小时候还加入了一个剧团。有兄弟姐妹吗？我有一个大姐姐，她也表演，但她是个画家。我还以为那是剧团的名字。我还以为杰森说的就像是“兄弟姐妹剧团”。
Right, that'd be a good one. Yeah, it is a good name. But she's a painter, yeah? She's a painter, yeah, yeah. Oh, wow. So the decision honestly was just, I mean, there was a moment when I got offered a job in a TV show, I was about 17, and had to make the decision
对，那会是个好名字。对，这确实是个好名字。但她是个画家，对吧？她是个画家，对，对。哦，哇。所以老实说，这个决定只是——我是说，当我有一次获得了一个在电视节目中工作的机会时，我大约17岁，不得不做出决定，
of leaving school, moving out. And they just sort of knew that was gonna happen and they made me promise if it didn't work out, I'd go back to school and I was like, of course. And, but they were incredibly supportive. So wait, did you not finish high school like me? No, didn't finish. Nice.
是离开学校还是搬出去。他们其实知道这会发生，他们让我保证如果行不通的话，我得回学校去，我当时就说，当然。而且，但他们极其支持我。等等，你和我一样没读完高中吗？对，没读完。太好了。
Wow. This is great, what I'm realizing also about your friendship with JB is that he hasn't asked you any questions about your life in all the time that you've been, no, no, it's fun. Dude, what's your last name? He's like, do you have a sister? Did you finish high school?
哇。太棒了，我同时意识到你和JB的友谊的一点是，在你们相处的这么长时间里，他竟然没有问过你任何关于你生活的问题，不，不，这很有趣。老兄，你贵姓？他就像是，你有姐姐吗？你读完高中了吗？
How the fuck would you not know that already? I'm not in there on the guy's jock all day on the fucking set, you know, we got work to do. It's called just human and rash, it's just called being interested in somebody else other than yourself. I gotta scroll through my phone in between takes. Jason and I stayed in character the whole time.
你怎么可能到现在都还不知道这些？我才不会整天在狗屎片场拍马屁呢，你知道的，我们还有工作要做。这叫有人情味，这叫对除了自己以外的人保持兴趣。我在两个镜头之间得刷手机。杰森和我全程都保持着角色状态。
Oh my God. We only talked. Oh my God. I will be honest, it was kind of weird when he shaved the beard because he'd been my big brother with the beard. Yeah. Like, you know, we'd been hugging and fighting
天哪。我们只交流。天哪。老实说，当他刮掉胡子时感觉有点奇怪，因为他一直是我那个留着胡子的老大哥。对。就像，你知道的，我们一直都在拥抱和打架，
and it's been full on and suddenly appeared and he was Jason Bateman. Yeah, T.V. Jason Bateman. Yeah, exactly. I know, you guys did so much storytelling together. Oh, God will. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
那是全情投入的，然后突然间他出现了，他成了杰森·贝特曼。对，电视里的杰森·贝特曼。对，没错。我知道，你们俩一起创作了那么多故事。哦，上帝，威尔。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。
So Jude, but that decision to go and do, to go do a television program or stay in school, when I hear you say it and I think about wanting to be a performer being 17, like that's a kind of an easy decision. Like, hey, do you want to go do that? Yeah. Or do you want to stay in school? I really love school.
所以，裘德，但是那个去拍电视剧还是留在学校的决定，当我听到你这么说，并且想到在17岁时想要成为一名表演者，就像那是一个相当简单的决定。就像，嘿，你想去拍那个吗？对。还是你想留在学校？我真的很喜欢学校。
Exactly. Yeah, when did you know that you in school? I really love school. Exactly. Yeah, when did you know that you were safe, that it was actually going to be something that could provide an income for you? Yeah. Honestly, not until I was in my early 20s and I'd done a movie or two and really, yeah. What was your first one?
没错。对，你是什么时候知道你在学校——我真的很喜欢学校。没错。对，你是什么时候知道你是安全的，这实际上会成为能为你提供收入的工作？对。老实说，直到我20岁出头拍了一两部电影之后，真的，是的。你的第一部是哪个？
What was your first film? So my first film was a movie called Shopping, and it was about car thieves, and that was in the early 90s. And then I did a film, another English film, but a period film called Wilde about Oscar Wilde, and Stephen Fry played Oscar Wilde, and I played his boyfriend, Bocey Douglas,
你的第一部电影是什么？所以我的第一部电影是一部叫《购物》的电影，讲的是汽车偷窃犯，那是90年代初。然后我拍了一部电影，另一部英国电影，但是一部历史古装片，讲的是奥斯卡·王尔德的《王尔德》，斯蒂芬·弗雷饰演奥斯卡·王尔德，我饰演他的男朋友波西·道格拉斯，
who was a nasty piece of work. And around then, I'd done a lot of theater in the film, yeah, I guess around then, I still thought, oh, this is a job. When was the move, you were still in England at that point. Well, Wild, you got, that was the first, like you got a little, you got some recognition
那是一个讨厌的家伙。大约在那个时候，我拍了很多戏剧和电影，是的，我想大约在那时，我还在想，哦，这是一个工作。什么时候搬走的，你当时还在英国。嗯，《王尔德》，你得到了，那是第一次，就像你得到了一点，你因为
for that performance in Wild. That kind of like put you up a notch. Yeah, I got those, you know, newcomer awards. Right. And,er awards and welcome to the gang awards kind of thing. Yeah. Well, that's kind of good though. I mean, that's kind of when you're a young actor, I mean, it's meaningful, yeah? Totally. But you know how it is.
在《王尔德》中的表演得到了一些认可。那有点像把你推上了一个新台阶。对，我得到了那些，你知道的，新人奖。没错。还有新人奖和欢迎加入帮派奖之类的东西。嗯，不过那挺不错的。我是说，当你是个年轻演员时，这很有意义，对吧？完全是的。但你知道那是怎么回事。
There's still that funny feeling of, God, I just want to get another job. You still think the unpredictable nature of what we do, the waiting is still quite alarming, and you haven't got enough money in the bank, like you're thinking, okay, God, this is unpredictable. Even today, all four of us are not out of the woods. We never will be. The only thing that I think we have going for us
那种奇怪的感觉依然挥之不去：天哪，我只是想再接一份工作。你仍然会觉得我们所做工作的不可预测性，那种等待仍然相当让人焦虑，而且你银行里的钱还不够，你会想，好吧，天哪，这太不可预测了。即使在今天，我们四个人也没有脱离险境。我们永远不会。我认为我们唯一的优势在于，
is that if our careers were to end soon, there would be sort of a downhill trajectory of maybe three or four jobs before you're done. Like, that's the only sort of pad we have built in there. Whereas like, back when Jude was starting, maybe, you know, this could be your last job. I think the four of us are at a point now, you know, with all of our, you know, we're so lucky to have had our sort of success, but it still only is built in like a three job off-ramp.
如果我们的职业生涯很快结束，可能会有一个由三四部作品组成的下滑轨迹，然后你才算彻底结束。就像，那是我们内置的唯一缓冲区。然而就像，回到裘德刚开始的时候，也许，你知道的，这可能是你的最后一份工作。我觉得我们四个人现在都到了这样一个阶段，你知道的，凭借我们所有的，你知道的，我们非常幸运能取得某种成功，但它依然只内置了一个三部作品的缓冲坡道。
Before nothing ever. Not if I release Sean's texts. I think it's gonna be immediate. But. I could use any. Jude, I will, so Jude, then, because I'm kind of building towards this, which is the film I think that I first,
在此之后就什么都没有了。除非我公开肖恩的短信。我觉得那会是即时的。不过。我可以用任何东西。裘德，我将，所以裘德，然后，因为我正朝着这个方向铺垫，也就是我认为我最初看到的那部电影，
that I as a consumer and a film goer, and as a young actor, looking, aspiring to do stuff, noticed you in a film that I to this day adore and talk about science fiction, a really pure, I think one of the great science fiction films, Gattaca, you and Ethan. That performance, that film... Andrew Nichol.
作为一个消费者和一个电影观众，作为一个年轻演员，在寻找、渴望做点什么的时候，我在一部我至今仍深爱并津津乐道的科幻电影中注意到了你，一部非常纯粹的科幻片，我认为是最伟大的科幻电影之一，《千钧一发》，你和伊桑。那种表演，那部电影……安德鲁·尼科尔。
Andrew Nichol. What an incredible, Andrew Nichol, amazing filmmaker. But that film was really remarkable. Talk a little bit about that, would you? Well, it was the first film that brought me to Hollywood, and it was the first time and, you know, it was one of those rare occasions where you read a script and you're, you just can't believe it's as good as it is,
安德鲁·尼科尔。多么不可思议的安德鲁·尼科尔，了不起的电影制作人。但那部电影真的很卓越。能稍微聊聊那个吗？嗯，那是把我带到好莱坞的第一部电影，也是第一次，而且，你知道，那是你读到一个剧本时极其罕见的时刻，你简直不敢相信它竟然这么好，
and that they want you to be in it. That was pretty extraordinary. You know, I was thinking a lot about that recently, and Ethan was such an incredible teacher, really. To meet and work with Ethan at that early formative moment was really impactful. He was, he's such a gent and he takes it so seriously but with such a humour and a creative sort of approach and I remember watching him and we had all our stuff together, that was really influential. But moving here, moving to the States and making a film.
他们希望你也能参与其中。这真是太不可思议了。你知道，我最近经常想起这件事，伊桑真的是一位不可思议的导师。在那个早期成长的阶段遇到伊桑并与他合作，真的影响深远。他这个人太温文尔雅了，他对待工作极其认真，但又带着幽默感和一种极具创造力的态度。我记得当时看着他，我们所有的东西都在一起，那真的很有影响力。但是搬到这里，搬到美国去拍电影。
And I remember going and rehearsing on the Sony lot. And yeah, it was just a dream. It was kind of fantastic, fantastical. Where did you move to? Where was your first spot? Oh, what was it called? I stayed- Were you down there in Culver City near the lot?
我还记得去索尼制片厂排练的情景。真的，简直就像一场梦。有点像梦幻一般，不可思议。你搬到哪里去了？你的第一个落脚点在哪里？哦，叫什么来着？我住在——你当时住在卡尔弗城制片厂附近吗？
No, I was in West Hollywood. I was in one of those funny little hotels where you've got a kitchen in the corner, something sweet, summer field sweet, something like that. Yeah, yeah. Where you have a bed and a little... Everything's in one room. Wasn't it as glamorous as you thought the Hollywood sort of journey would be? Honestly, I was just happy someone else was picking up the bill.
不，我在西好莱坞。我住在那些有趣的小酒店里，角落里有个厨房，感觉挺温馨的，萨姆菲尔德甜蜜酒店之类的地方，大概吧。对，对。就是那种有一张床和一个小厨房……所有东西都在同一个房间里。是不是不像你想象中好莱坞式的旅程那么光鲜亮丽？老实说，我当时只高兴有人帮我买单。
At that point, you were just happy it wasn't raining. I think, you know, you talk about Ethan, first of all, I do want to say this, and we've had him on the show, we're such fans, I think he is such an unheralded artist. And I don't usually use that word as much because, but sometimes it makes me cringe, but he is such an artist, that guy,
在那时，你只高兴没下雨就行。我想，你知道的，你谈到伊桑，首先，我真的想说，我们之前邀请过他上节目，我们是他的超级粉丝，我认为他是一位极其被低估的艺术家。我平时不怎么常用这个词，因为有时它会让我觉得有点矫情，但他真的是个不折不扣的艺术家，那个家伙，
and he is, and started young as we know, he was a child actor. We're talking about Ethan Hawke. Ethan Hawke, yeah, sorry Tracey, we're talking about Ethan Hawke. He's one of those guys, he could have, if he had had more artistry, Jason could have been him, but he's one of those, and I say that,
而且他确实是，正如我们所知，他很小就出道了，是个童星。我们说的是伊桑·霍克。伊桑·霍克，对，抱歉特雷西，我们在说伊桑·霍克。他是那种人，如果他更有艺术造诣的话，杰森也许就能成为他了，但他就是那种人，我是说——
Jason, and I love what you do. It feels like a compliment. No it is. I just gotta kinda look into It feels like a compliment. No, it is. I just gotta kinda look into it a little bit. No, but he is, he's kind of like, I really do, I love, A, all his performances are so good and so raw and amazing, and I love his approach and hearing him talk about art.
杰森，我喜欢你做的事情。听起来像是个夸奖。不，是的。我只是得仔细琢磨一下——听起来像是个夸奖。不，确实是。我只是得稍微琢磨一下。不，不过他是那种人，我真的很喜欢，首先，他的所有表演都那么精彩、质朴且惊艳，我喜欢他的创作方法以及听他谈论艺术。
So when you told me that you learn a lot, I believe that. I believe that that relationship was inspiring. Generous too. That's another thing. Really generous on set. And aware that he was working with someone who was pretty green. I mean, I'd only done a couple of films and I'm still a little bit like this. Just warm and yeah, it was a very happy time.
所以当你告诉我你学到了很多东西时，我相信这一点。我相信那段关系极具启发性。而且他还很大方。这是另一件事。在片场真的很大方。并且意识到他合作的是一个相当青涩的新人。我的意思是，我当时只拍过几部电影，而且我现在有时也还是这样。非常温暖，是的，那是一段非常快乐的时光。
But here's the funny thing, again, too young to realize that that doesn't mean the film's gonna be a hit, right? So you sit there going, wow, I'm in Hollywood, and this is, it's really good, and it is, it's a great film, and the proof with that one is that people still refer to it. Thank you for what you said, and you're right, it holds up.
但有趣的是，那时又太年轻，没意识到这并不意味着电影一定会大火，对吧？所以你坐在那里想，哇，我在好莱坞，这真的很棒，事实也确实如此，这是一部伟大的电影，而这部电影的证明就是人们至今仍然会提起它。谢谢你所说的话，你说得对，它经受住了时间的考验。
Oh my God. But at the time, it just sort of disappeared. And I kind of, you know, that was my first taste of, oh, you gotta keep trying. You gotta keep throwing the spaghetti at the wall cause nothing, till it sticks, right? But, yeah, you know, it's funny, you do have that, again, as a consumer of it,
天哪。但当时，它就那样默默无闻地消失了。我当时，你知道，那是我的初次体验，哦，你得继续努力。你得不断地尝试各种可能，直到成功为止，对吧？但是，是的，你知道，这很有趣，你确实会有这种感觉，再次作为它的消费者，
and somebody who watched it and adored it, to me, it's funny you do have that again as the moot as a consumer of it and somebody who watched it and adored it To me to me It was a hit in the sense that it worked and it was brilliant and all that kind of so I walked out of the theater With whomever and say like god that was an incredible film and blah blah So I sort of put it in that place that it's an incredible film. I don't know if the Happens yeah the accounts at the studio... No, exactly. But it's funny how, you know, if it stays in your...
and somebody who watched it and adored it, to me, it's funny you do have that again as the moot as a consumer of it and somebody who watched it and adored it To me to me It was a hit in the sense that it worked and it was brilliant and all that kind of so I walked out of the theater With whomever and say like god that was an incredible film and blah blah So I sort of put it in that place that it's an incredible film. I don't know if the Happens yeah the accounts at the studio... No, exactly. But it's funny how, you know, if it stays in your...|||而且作为一个观看并喜爱它的人，对我来说，有趣的是，作为它的消费者以及一个看过并热爱它的人，你会再次拥有这种感觉。对我来说，它是一部热门作品，因为它奏效了，而且它很精彩，诸如此类。所以我走出电影院时，和某人一起，就会说，天哪，那真是一部不可思议的电影，诸如此类。所以我把它放在“这是一部不可思议的电影”这个位置上。我不知道这是否真的发生过，是的，工作室的账目……不，完全是这样。但有趣的是，你知道，如果它留在你的……
I mean, it's not one of those we look back on and go, it worked at the time, but, you know, again, this is why it's such a shame in a way that films are judged on their, you know, opening weekend. Box office. Box office. You think, let's come back and re-review this in five years, ten. Well, that's one of the things I like about streaming,
I mean, it's not one of those we look back on and go, it worked at the time, but, you know, again, this is why it's such a shame in a way that films are judged on their, you know, opening weekend. Box office. Box office. You think, let's come back and re-review this in five years, ten. Well, that's one of the things I like about streaming,|||我的意思是，它不是那种我们回过头去看，然后说“它在当时很管用，但是……”的作品。你知道，再次说明，这就是为什么从某种意义上说，电影以首周末票房来衡量是如此令人遗憾的事情。票房。票房。你会想，让我们在五年、十年后再来重新评估这部作品。好吧，这也是我喜欢流媒体的地方之一，
right, like there is no sort of scorecard, there's no sort of results, it's just, it's up there, and if you like it, you tell somebody about it, and then they watch it, they might like it, and it's just, people then experience it when they want, how they want, and I like that it's just on the merits. There's no, it's not qualified by. And old catalogs get rediscovered again, right?
right, like there is no sort of scorecard, there's no sort of results, it's just, it's up there, and if you like it, you tell somebody about it, and then they watch it, they might like it, and it's just, people then experience it when they want, how they want, and I like that it's just on the merits. There's no, it's not qualified by. And old catalogs get rediscovered again, right?|||对吧，就像没有什么记分牌，没有什么结果，它就在那里，如果你喜欢它，你就会告诉别人，然后他们去看，他们可能会喜欢，然后人们就会在他们想的时候、以他们想要的方式去体验它，我喜欢这种完全凭内容本身优劣说话的感觉。没有什么，它不受……的限制。而且旧片库又被重新发现了，对吧？
Yeah. Isn't that someone was saying that Grey's Anatomy is this show that is suddenly being watched by everybody. Oh, all these shows, what's the show? Suits. Suits. Yeah, yeah. Suits has had this thing where everybody's, people are like, oh, have you watched Suits? But I wonder what the algorithm or their thing it says,
Yeah. Isn't that someone was saying that Grey's Anatomy is this show that is suddenly being watched by everybody. Oh, all these shows, what's the show? Suits. Suits. Yeah, yeah. Suits has had this thing where everybody's, people are like, oh, have you watched Suits? But I wonder what the algorithm or their thing it says,|||是的。不是有人说《实习医生格蕾》是一部突然被所有人观看的剧吗？哦，所有这些剧，什么剧来着？《金装律师》。《金装律师》。对，对。《金装律师》就有这样一种现象，每个人都在谈论，人们会说，哦，你看过《金装律师》吗？但我很好奇算法或他们的系统是怎么说的，
let's try Suits, let's try Grey's Anatomy, you know? Like, I wonder, I don't know if it's interesting. You know, Jude, you go ahead. Sorry, Sean. No, I was just, you go, you go, you go, you go. You know what? I'm going to go. I was just going to say this, which is,
let's try Suits, let's try Grey's Anatomy, you know? Like, I wonder, I don't know if it's interesting. You know, Jude, you go ahead. Sorry, Sean. No, I was just, you go, you go, you go, you go. You know what? I'm going to go. I was just going to say this, which is,|||让我们试试《金装律师》，让我们试试《实习医生格蕾》，你知道吗？就像，我在想，我不知道这是否有趣。你知道，裘德，你先说。对不起，肖恩。不，我只是，你先说，你先说，你先说，你先说。你知道吗？我来说。我刚才正要说这个，那就是，
so you do Gattaca and you come out and it brings you out here and it kind of introduces, and brings you to Hollywood. And then what was the gap? You did that and then you did, I want to say that you did, well, the time between that and Talented Mr. Ripley. Yeah.
so you do Gattaca and you come out and it brings you out here and it kind of introduces, and brings you to Hollywood. And then what was the gap? You did that and then you did, I want to say that you did, well, the time between that and Talented Mr. Ripley. Yeah.|||所以你拍了《变种 DNA》，然后你出来了，这把你带到了这里，它有点像引荐，把你带到了好莱坞。然后中间的空档期是什么？你拍了那个，然后你拍了——我想说你拍了，嗯，那部电影和《天才雷普利》之间的时间。是的。
Because those were both late 90s films that were really amazing, impactful films. Yeah, Ripley really raised my game because of nominations and the other people in it. There was a little bit of a... There were a few tumbleweed moments between Gattaca and Ripley where because Gattaca hadn't been a financial hit, I did a couple of smaller parts, but still, there's that thing of, it's not consistent.
Because those were both late 90s films that were really amazing, impactful films. Yeah, Ripley really raised my game because of nominations and the other people in it. There was a little bit of a... There were a few tumbleweed moments between Gattaca and Ripley where because Gattaca hadn't been a financial hit, I did a couple of smaller parts, but still, there's that thing of, it's not consistent.|||因为这两部都是90年代末非常惊艳、极具影响力的电影。是的，《天才雷普利》确实提升了我的水平，因为获得了提名，还有片中的其他人。有一点……在《变种 DNA》和《天才雷普利》之间有那么几个像风滚草一样尴尬冷清的时刻，因为《变种 DNA》在商业上没有大获成功，我演了一些小角色，但尽管如此，还是有那种情况，就是不够连贯。
And Ripley really was a leap for me. And then you were on the set with another gem, Matt Damon. I'll bet you had a great time with him too. Yeah, I mean, he could be, he's a little, I mean. He's not bright, but. No, he's not bright. Matt's really not that bright. He's not bright, but. No, he's not bright. Matt's really not that bright. He's really hot and cold, let's be honest.
And Ripley really was a leap for me. And then you were on the set with another gem, Matt Damon. I'll bet you had a great time with him too. Yeah, I mean, he could be, he's a little, I mean. He's not bright, but. No, he's not bright. Matt's really not that bright. He's not bright, but. No, he's not bright. Matt's really not that bright. He's really hot and cold, let's be honest.|||而《天才雷普利》对我来说确实是一个飞跃。然后你和另一位宝藏演员马特·达蒙一起在片场。我敢说你和他在一起也过得很愉快。是的，我的意思是，他可能会，他有点，我的意思是。他不聪明，但是。不，他确实不聪明。马特真的没那么聪明。他不聪明，但。不，他确实不聪明。马特真的没那么聪明。说实话，他这人阴晴不定的。
And he blew it, he blew it at Wordle this morning. I will say. Yeah, I busted two days ago, I bet you did too. I did not, everybody else busted on that day and I did not, I got a six. What was it again? Was it radar or something like that? No, no, no, no, I'll tell you right now,
And he blew it, he blew it at Wordle this morning. I will say. Yeah, I busted two days ago, I bet you did too. I did not, everybody else busted on that day and I did not, I got a six. What was it again? Was it radar or something like that? No, no, no, no, I'll tell you right now,|||而且他搞砸了，他今天早上在Wordle游戏里搞砸了。我得这么说。是的，我两天前连击断了，我打赌你也是。我没有，那天其他人全断了，但我没有，我用了六次猜出来。那是个什么词来着？是“radar”（雷达）还是别的什么？不，不，不，不，我现在就告诉你，
because Bob texted me about it, and he was like, what did you get today? Have you tried Quirtle? Oh my, don't get him started, Jude. I do Quirtle, Octurdle, and Wirtle, all three every morning with Matt and two other guys, every morning for three years. That's consistent.
because Bob texted me about it, and he was like, what did you get today? Have you tried Quirtle? Oh my, don't get him started, Jude. I do Quirtle, Octurdle, and Wirtle, all three every morning with Matt and two other guys, every morning for three years. That's consistent.|||因为鲍勃给我发短信说这事，他问我：“你今天得了几分？”“你试过Quirtle了吗？”天哪，别让他打开话匣子，裘德。我每天早上都和马特还有另外两个人一起玩Quirtle、Octurdle和Wirtle这三个游戏，每天早上，已经坚持三年了。这可真够持之以恒的。
Every morning. Okay, get back to your guest. So, get back to your guest. Wait, so you do a couple of tumbleweeds and then you do Ripley. Did you know Anthony Minghella before? No, he... I was working... I did this really odd little film with a director from Hong Kong and Anthony's wife was one of the producers on it.
Every morning. Okay, get back to your guest. So, get back to your guest. Wait, so you do a couple of tumbleweeds and then you do Ripley. Did you know Anthony Minghella before? No, he... I was working... I did this really odd little film with a director from Hong Kong and Anthony's wife was one of the producers on it.|||每天早上。好的，回到你的嘉宾上来。所以，回到你的嘉宾上来。等等，所以你经历了几段尴尬期，然后你拍了《天才雷普利》。你之前认识安东尼·明格拉吗？不，他……我在工作……我拍了一部非常古怪的小电影，导演来自香港，安东尼的妻子是该片的制片人之一。
And he was watching the rushes for that while he was casting. I mean, I look back on that decision. That's the way that that works. I don't know how, I mean, I don't know what he saw. I can take it. It's amazing, it's amazing. Saw some raw talent and somebody pretty easy on the ice. Hell of a leap, though.
And he was watching the rushes for that while he was casting. I mean, I look back on that decision. That's the way that that works. I don't know how, I mean, I don't know what he saw. I can take it. It's amazing, it's amazing. Saw some raw talent and somebody pretty easy on the ice. Hell of a leap, though.|||他当时在选角的时候正在看那部电影的毛片。我的意思是，我回想起那个决定。事情就是这样运作的。我不知道怎么回事，我的意思是，我不知道他看到了什么。我能接受。这太神奇了，太神奇了。看到了某种未经雕琢的天赋，以及一个在镜头前挺放松的人。不过这真是一个巨大的飞跃。
Was his daughter Hannah around, the great Hannah Mingala? The great Hannah. And Max, who's now a director, the great Hannah Mingala? The great Hannah. Max, who's now a director, was like a little boy on set of that, he was, I think, I'm going to say 10. Was Hannah there too? Hannah was around, yeah, absolutely. Right, and in that way, now that was shot
Was his daughter Hannah around, the great Hannah Mingala? The great Hannah. And Max, who's now a director, the great Hannah Mingala? The great Hannah. Max, who's now a director, was like a little boy on set of that, he was, I think, I'm going to say 10. Was Hannah there too? Hannah was around, yeah, absolutely. Right, and in that way, now that was shot|||他的女儿汉娜在场吗？伟大的汉娜·明格拉？伟大的汉娜。还有现在成为导演的马克斯，伟大的汉娜·明格拉？伟大的汉娜。现在成为导演的马克斯在当时片场就像个小男孩，他当时，我想，大概10岁吧。汉娜也在吗？汉娜在场，是的，绝对在。对，而且就那样，当时那部戏是在
in some beautiful spots too, right? Yeah, I mean, I look, you know, on location all down the coast in Italy, we rehearsed at the famous Cina Cita studio in Rome, and then we shot in Rome, we shot in Ischia, which is this beautiful island off Naples. Near Capri. Near Capri.
in some beautiful spots too, right? Yeah, I mean, I look, you know, on location all down the coast in Italy, we rehearsed at the famous Cina Cita studio in Rome, and then we shot in Rome, we shot in Ischia, which is this beautiful island off Naples. Near Capri. Near Capri.|||一些非常美丽的地方拍摄的，对吧？是的，我的意思是，你看，我们在意大利海岸沿线实地取景，我们在罗马著名的切奇塔（Cinecittà）电影制片厂排练，然后在罗马拍摄，我们在伊斯基亚拍摄，那是那座位于那不勒斯附近的美丽岛屿。在卡布里岛附近。在卡布里岛附近。
There's three, then Progedo, and yeah, it was beautiful. So that, go ahead, Ron. But you're down there, sorry, I just wanna say, because I, oh God, this is so delicious to me. It's you and- Sean, I think Will's falling as much in love with him as I am, and I'm gonna battle him. I've been in love with him.
There's three, then Progedo, and yeah, it was beautiful. So that, go ahead, Ron. But you're down there, sorry, I just wanna say, because I, oh God, this is so delicious to me. It's you and- Sean, I think Will's falling as much in love with him as I am, and I'm gonna battle him. I've been in love with him.|||有三个，然后是普罗奇达，是的，那里很美。所以，说吧，罗恩。但你在那边，对不起，我只想说，因为我，哦天哪，这对我来说太美妙了。是你和——肖恩，我觉得威尔爱上他的程度不亚于我，我要跟他决斗。我早就爱上他了。
I'm gonna duel with Will. I've been in love with Jude since we had that dinner over at our buddy's house a few months ago. Wait, what? What a great dinner. Yeah. You were there too. I thought it was a table for two.
I'm gonna duel with Will. I've been in love with Jude since we had that dinner over at our buddy's house a few months ago. Wait, what? What a great dinner. Yeah. You were there too. I thought it was a table for two.|||我要和威尔决斗。自从几个月前我们在朋友家吃过那顿晚宴之后，我就一直爱上裘德了。等等，什么？多么棒的一顿晚餐啊。是的。你当时也在。我还以为那是二人桌呢。
We were all there. That was a great dinner. So it was you and Matt and Gwyneth Paltrow and Phil Hoffman. Phil Hoffman. The great Phil Hoffman, Kate Bunchett. I mean, and then Anthony Minghella directing and you're in Italy.
We were all there. That was a great dinner. So it was you and Matt and Gwyneth Paltrow and Phil Hoffman. Phil Hoffman. The great Phil Hoffman, Kate Bunchett. I mean, and then Anthony Minghella directing and you're in Italy.|||我们都在那儿。那真是一顿丰盛的晚餐。所以当时有你、马特、格温妮丝·帕特洛和菲尔·霍夫曼。菲尔·霍夫曼。伟大的菲尔·霍夫曼，凯特·布兰切特。我的意思是，还有安东尼·明格拉执导，而你们在意大利。
And my question is, when you do something like that, it's kind of like the Gattaca thing in a way, but it's different. Are you able to, in the moment, did you appreciate it? Did you have moments where you went like, man, this is really amazing? Or not?
And my question is, when you do something like that, it's kind of like the Gattaca thing in a way, but it's different. Are you able to, in the moment, did you appreciate it? Did you have moments where you went like, man, this is really amazing? Or not?|||我的问题是，当你做这样一件事时，在某种程度上它有点像《变种 DNA》那次，但又有所不同。你在当时能够去欣赏它吗？你有过那种觉得“天哪，这太棒了”的时刻吗？还是没有？
Is it wasted on you? Not as much as I wish I had. Yeah, yeah, yeah. There was a bit of me looking back. But now you can, I'll bet. Well, yeah, I'm better at it, but there's, you know, in that, I kind of thought, well, this is what movies are like,
Is it wasted on you? Not as much as I wish I had. Yeah, yeah, yeah. There was a bit of me looking back. But now you can, I'll bet. Well, yeah, I'm better at it, but there's, you know, in that, I kind of thought, well, this is what movies are like,|||这是否被你白白辜负了？不像我希望的那样懂得珍惜。对，对，对。我回顾过去时确实有这种感觉。但现在你可以了，我敢打赌。嗯，是的，我现在更擅长这个了，但是，你知道，在当时，我有点认为，嗯，电影就是这样的，
you know, sitting on a beach and sailing a yacht and hanging out with all these cool young movie stars. And it was exceptionally special because of the goodwill that Anthony had deservedly been given through the success of the English patient and the people that he had assembled were a pretty extraordinary group from the cast to all the crew.
you know, sitting on a beach and sailing a yacht and hanging out with all these cool young movie stars. And it was exceptionally special because of the goodwill that Anthony had deservedly been given through the success of the English patient and the people that he had assembled were a pretty extraordinary group from the cast to all the crew.|||你知道的，坐在沙滩上，开着游艇，和所有这些酷炫的年轻电影明星一起闲逛。而且它格外特殊，因为安东尼凭借《英国病人》的成功理所应当地赢得了人们的善意，他召集的人从演员到全体剧组人员，都是一群非常了不起的人。
It was a great experience and I wish I'd been a little better at just living in it and realizing how special it was. But the number of projects that you've done, speaking about your ability to assess whether you're on board a sinking ship or not, it's just the number of projects that you've done is just outstanding.
It was a great experience and I wish I'd been a little better at just living in it and realizing how special it was. But the number of projects that you've done, speaking about your ability to assess whether you're on board a sinking ship or not, it's just the number of projects that you've done is just outstanding.|||这是一次极好的经历，我只希望当时自己能更擅长去享受当下，并意识到它是多么的特别。不过你做过的项目数量，说到你评估自己是否在一条沉船上的能力，你参与的项目数量简直太惊人了。
And they're all like huge hits. Well, yeah, I mean, there's a lot of people that have worked a lot, but it's just because they don't like home and they'll just do whatever. Everything you've done has been incredible. You've certainly been incredible in it. Some of, you know, out of your own power. JB, but some of the, but also, not just the volume,
And they're all like huge hits. Well, yeah, I mean, there's a lot of people that have worked a lot, but it's just because they don't like home and they'll just do whatever. Everything you've done has been incredible. You've certainly been incredible in it. Some of, you know, out of your own power. JB, but some of the, but also, not just the volume,|||而且它们都像巨大轰动一作。嗯，是的，我的意思是，有很多工作很多的人，但这只是因为他们不喜欢待在家里，所以他们什么都愿意做。你做过的一切都令人难以置信。你在其中的表现当然也极其出色。你知道，其中有些，超出了你自身的控制力，JB，但有些，而且，不仅仅是数量，
but how different a lot of them have been tonally. And also just like doing Shakespeare on Broadway and shit. I mean like this guy, you don't know what you're dealing with with this guy. Jude, I remember like Jason just said, all of these great things that you've done your whole life. And then I remember when Spy came out with Melissa McCarthy and I was like, is that Jude Law?
but how different a lot of them have been tonally. And also just like doing Shakespeare on Broadway and shit. I mean like this guy, you don't know what you're dealing with with this guy. Jude, I remember like Jason just said, all of these great things that you've done your whole life. And then I remember when Spy came out with Melissa McCarthy and I was like, is that Jude Law?|||而是它们在基调上有多少是如此不同。还有就像在百老汇演莎士比亚戏剧之类的。我的意思是，像这家伙，你不知道你在跟一个什么样的人打交道。裘德，我记得就像刚才杰森说的，你这一生做过了不起的各种事情。然后我记得梅丽ッ萨·麦卡西主演的《女间谍》上映时，我就想：那是裘德·洛吗？
Like it was the greatest left-hand turn ever. I was like, I've never seen Jude do something like this. It was so good. I was just mad about her. I just so wanted to work with her. She's incredible. And witness. I think a lot of, honestly,
Like it was the greatest left-hand turn ever. I was like, I never seen Jude do something like this. It was so good. I was just mad about her. I just so wanted to work with her. She's incredible. And witness. I think a lot of, honestly,|||就像这是有史以来最棒的华丽转身。我当时想：我从未见过裘德做过这样的事。太棒了。我简直对她着迷。我太想和她合作了。她太不可思议了。去见证。说实话，我觉得很大程度上，
I've been thinking about this recently about what kind of drives me. And a lot of it is curiosity. It's why I've kind of done different franchises too. I sort of, you know, I really, I'm a bit of a film nerd, like I just love going to the movies and going to, you know, seeing stuff and having an opinion, but I'm also kind of dead curious about how do they do that? How's that done? And she was, she was flying at that time and her and Paul Faghe and that work that they were doing, I just wanted to witness it. I'll be honest, I did not feel I was in my comfort zone.
I've been thinking about this recently about what kind of drives me. And a lot of it is curiosity. It's why I've kind of done different franchises too. I sort of, you know, I really, I'm a bit of a film nerd, like I just love going to the movies and going to, you know, seeing stuff and having an opinion, but I'm also kind of dead curious about how do they do that? How's that done? And she was, she was flying at that time and her and Paul Faghe and that work that they were doing, I just wanted to witness it. I'll be honest, I did not feel I was in my comfort zone.|||我最近一直在思考是什么在驱使着我。很大一部分原因就是好奇心。这也是我为什么会接拍不同系列电影的原因。我有点，你知道，我真的，我有点像个电影书呆子，我就是喜欢去看电影，去看各种东西并拥有自己的见解，但我也对“他们是怎么做到的？那是怎么拍出来的？”充满了强烈的好奇心。她当时正处于事业的巅峰期，她和保罗·费格当时正在进行的那种创作，我只是想去见证它。说实话，我觉得自己当时并不在舒适区内。
I was sad. There's a scene opposite her. I suddenly realized very clearly, oh, you're the straight guy. Okay, this is fine, I can play that. Because Paul's coming over writing all these notes, going try that, try this, and she's just firing off. I mean, I'm holding it together,
I was sad. There's a scene opposite her. I suddenly realized very clearly, oh, you're the straight guy. Okay, this is fine, I can play that. Because Paul's coming over writing all these notes, going try that, try this, and she's just firing off. I mean, I'm holding it together,|||我很沮丧。有一场和她对戏的戏。我突然非常清晰地意识到：哦，原来你是那个正经严肃的白脸角色（Straight man）。好吧，这没问题，我能演这个。因为保罗跑过来写了各种笔记，说试试这个，试试那个，而她则在即兴疯狂输出。我的意思是，我在勉强撑住，
just trying to keeping a straight face, right? I'm just sort of, just don't lose it and really make a fool of yourself. But my goodness, the speed and the ideas, and then just talk about going off on a tangent. You're sitting there thinking, what are you talking about? She's an absolute comedy titan. I mean, Melissa McCarthy is great.
just trying to keeping a straight face, right? I'm just sort of, just don't lose it and really make a fool of yourself. But my goodness, the speed and the ideas, and then just talk about going off on a tangent. You're sitting there thinking, what are you talking about? She's an absolute comedy titan. I mean, Melissa McCarthy is great.|||只想保持扑克脸，对吧？我只是在想，千万别破功，别让自己当众出丑。但我的天哪，那个语速和那些点子，然后简直是思维完全跑偏。你坐在那儿想：你在说什么呢？她绝对是喜剧界的大佬。我是说，梅丽莎·麦卡西太棒了。
And also, by the way, should we mention our good friend, my good friend Jason, yours too, Pete Sarah Fenowich is in that film as well. Yes. The lovely Pete. He's fantastic in that film. There's a scene where the two of them, I think, handcuff together, right?
And also, by the way, should we mention our good friend, my good friend Jason, yours too, Pete Sarah Fenowich is in that film as well. Yes. The lovely Pete. He's fantastic in that film. There's a scene where the two of them, I think, handcuff together, right?|||另外，顺便说一句，我们是不是该提一下我们的好朋友、我的好朋友杰森，也是你的朋友，皮特·塞拉芬诺维奇也在那部电影里。是的。可爱的皮特。他在那部电影里表现太棒了。有一个场景，他们俩好像被手铐铐在一起了，对吧？
And they're kind of lying on top. So it's a weird sort of sexy makeout scene. Kind of we escape. God, he's good. He's so good, and by the way, a great Pete Serif and a great story. Last year, I hadn't spoken to him in about 18 months, maybe almost two years, and we were quite good friends years ago.
And they're kind of lying on top. So it's a weird sort of sexy makeout scene. Kind of we escape. God, he's good. He's so good, and by the way, a great Pete Serif and a great story. Last year, I hadn't spoken to him in about 18 months, maybe almost two years, and we were quite good friends years ago.|||然后他们有点叠躺在一起。所以这是一个奇怪的带点性感色彩的亲热戏。有点像我们逃跑。天哪，他演得真好。他太棒了，顺便说一句，伟大的皮特·塞拉芬和一个棒极了的故事。去年，我和他大约有18个月没说话了，可能快两年了，而我们几年前曾是非常好的朋友。
I mean, we still are, but we sort of hadn't talked to each other, and out of the blue, I texted him, so what else is going on? And after a while, I saw that it had been a couple years, and he answered almost immediately, that's about it. So funny. So Jude, with all of the great incoming calls
I mean, we still are, but we sort of hadn't talked to each other, and out of the blue, I texted him, so what else is going on? And after a while, I saw that it had been a couple years, and he answered almost immediately, that's about it. So funny. So Jude, with all of the great incoming calls|||我的意思是，我们现在仍然是，但我们有一段时间没联系了，突然之间，我给他发了条短信：最近还有什么新鲜事？过了一会儿，我发现已经过去好几年了，他几乎立刻就回了信息，差不多就是这样。太搞笑了。所以裘德，面对所有这些源源不断打来的优秀电话，
I'm sure you get, how do you, is there, I'm sure you base your choices on many, is there, I'm sure you base your choices on many, many things, but is there one thing that is above all else will drag you towards a project? Is it the director? Sorry, I was just saying, is this things like money? No, yeah, of course. Well, but I mean, look, you know,
I'm sure you get, how do you, is there, I'm sure you base your choices on many, is there, I'm sure you base your choices on many, many things, but is there one thing that is above all else will drag you towards a project? Is it the director? Sorry, I was just saying, is this things like money? No, yeah, of course. Well, but I mean, look, you know,|||我相信你一定接到了不少，你是如何，有没有——我相信你的选择基于很多因素，有没有——我相信你的选择基于许许多多的事情，但有没有一件事高于一切，能够把你吸引到一个项目里？是导演吗？对不起，我刚才是在说，这是像金钱这样的东西吗？不，是的，当然。嗯，但是我的意思是，听着，你知道，
there's, everyone needs it. Is it filmmaker, is it role, is it location, is it money, is it schedule? Is there one thing that is most important to you ever, or has it changed? I kind of balance it up. I love the idea of a challenge, a little bit like the role I play in The Order,
there's, everyone needs it. Is it filmmaker, is it role, is it location, is it money, is it schedule? Is there one thing that is most important to you ever, or has it changed? I kind of balance it up. I love the idea of a challenge, a little bit like the role I play in The Order,|||每个人都需要它。是电影制作人，是角色，是拍摄地点，是金钱，还是档期？有没有哪一件事对你来说永远是最重要的，还是说它一直在变？我基本上会把它们权衡一下。我很喜欢挑战的概念，有点像我在《秩序》中扮演的角色，
which just felt like something completely new and different and the opportunity to work with someone like Justin on that, who I knew I was in good hands, and he'd sort of take me there. He's the director. You know, those films, Justin Curzell, yeah. And he... That experience was a very good experience, but you have to balance a film like that with... Then I was like, okay, now I need to pay my rent.
which just felt like something completely new and different and the opportunity to work with someone like Justin on that, who I knew I was in good hands, and he'd sort of take me there. He's the director. You know, those films, Justin Curzell, yeah. And he... That experience was a very good experience, but you have to balance a film like that with... Then I was like, okay, now I need to pay my rent.|||感觉这是一个完全崭新且不同的东西，而且有机会和像贾斯汀这样的人合作，我知道我遇到了靠谱的人，他会带我进入那个世界。他是导演。你知道的，那些电影，贾斯汀·库泽尔，是的。他……那次经历是一次非常好的经历，但你必须将这样一部电影与……然后我就想：好吧，现在我得交房租了。
So, you know, you've got to kind of find something that's going to balance that out, you know, then I was like, okay, now I need to pay my rent. So you got to kind of find something that's going to balance that out, but also... Black rabbit. I'm curious. God, he fucked you. What a shot in the nuts. He did your thing for the money. Fuck, dude.
So, you know, you've got to kind of find something that's going to balance that out, you know, then I was like, okay, now I need to pay my rent. So you got to kind of find something that's going to balance that out, but also... Black rabbit. I'm curious. God, he fucked you. What a shot in the nuts. He did your thing for the money. Fuck, dude.|||所以，你知道，你得找点东西来平衡一下，你知道，然后我就想：好吧，现在我得交房租了。所以你得找点东西来平衡一下，但同时……《黑兔》。我很好奇。天哪，他坑了你。这回击太致命了。他接你的项目纯粹是为了钱。操，老兄。
You're in love with the guy. You've had a great experience and he only did it for the fucking dough. And while he was there, he did a great job. You're a paycheck to him. Keep going, dude. Sorry I interrupted. It's all... It's... I mean, you mentioned kind of all the boxes that you check, right? And all of them at a different time have a different order.
You're in love with the guy. You've had a great experience and he only did it for the fucking dough. And while he was there, he did a great job. You're a paycheck to him. Keep going, dude. Sorry I interrupted. It's all... It's... I mean, you mentioned kind of all the boxes that you check, right? And all of them at a different time have a different order.|||你爱上了这个家伙。你们有过一次美妙的经历，而他这么干纯粹是为了该死的钞票。但在他在那儿的时候，他干得非常漂亮。对卡来说，你只是一张薪水支票。继续，老兄。抱歉我打断了。这一切都是……这是……我的意思是，你提到了你挑选剧本时会勾选的各种标准，对吧？在不同的时期，所有这些标准都有不同的优先级排序。
So sometimes, yeah, it's where are we filming this? Who's in it? All of those things come to play. Family, like where bringing kids and all that kind of stuff is important too. Yeah, so, I mean, specifically over the last two years, I've got a house that's being renovated and I'm having one of those nightmests.
So sometimes, yeah, it's where are we filming this? Who's in it? All of those things come to play. Family, like where bringing kids and all that kind of stuff is important too. Yeah, so, I mean, specifically over the last two years, I've got a house that's being renovated and I'm having one of those nightmests.|||所以有时，是的，这取决于我们在哪里拍摄？谁参演了？所有这些因素都会发挥作用。家庭，比如带着孩子去哪里之类的事情也很重要。是的，所以，我的意思是，具体来说在过去的两年里，我有一栋房子正在装修，我正经历着那种装修噩梦。
And it's just going on and on and on. So me and my wife and the two little ones, I've just been like, okay, well, let's just travel the world. Let's just go wherever I'm working. So we've been- For like two years. For two years, so we really have. We've been in California, then we were in Canada
And it's just going on and on and on. So me and my wife and the two little ones, I've just been like, okay, well, let's just travel the world. Let's just go wherever I'm working. So we've been- For like two years. For two years, so we really have. We've been in California, then we were in Canada|||而且这事没完没了，一直在继续。所以我和我妻子还有两个小家伙，我就想：好吧，那我们就环游世界吧。我工作到哪儿我们就去哪儿。所以我们一直在——大概两年了吧。整整两年，所以我们真的是这样。我们去过加利福尼亚，然后去了加拿大，
and then France and then Australia and then New York. So it's been, it's been wild. But that, so it really has been just following the work. And the kids love it? And they're very little. They're both under five, so it's not like, as long as we're both there looking calm and happy. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
and then France and then Australia and then New York. So it's been, it's been wild. But that, so it really has been just following the work. And the kids love it? And they're very little. They're both under five, so it's not like, as long as we're both there looking calm and happy. Yeah, yeah, yeah.|||然后去了法国，然后去了澳大利亚，然后去了纽约。所以这段经历，简直太疯狂了。但这就是，所以真的就是跟着工作走。孩子们喜欢这样吗？而且他们还很小。他们两个都不到五岁，所以还不算什么，只要我们俩都在那儿显得平静而快乐。对，对，对。
They're calm and happy. Exactly, exactly. Do you ever find, I always find that fascinating when you do have this schedule that you do. Do you miss a home base? Do you miss a groundedness to come back to? I thought I would more, but I really haven't. And we've found some really beautiful homes around,
They're calm and happy. Exactly, exactly. Do you ever find, I always find that fascinating when you do have this schedule that you do. Do you miss a home base? Do you miss a groundedness to come back to? I thought I would more, but I really haven't. And we've found some really beautiful homes around,|||他们很平静很快乐。没错，没错。你有没有发现，每当你拥有这样紧凑的日程安排时，我都觉得这太迷人了。你会想念一个大本营吗？你会想念那种可以返回的踏实感吗？我原以为我会更想念，但我真的没有。而且我们在各地找到了一些非常漂亮的房子，
and some not so great, but mostly really good experiences. I tell you what I have found hard. I found it really hard going back to UK, because without my house, like I had this lovely home there for... I've always lived there. But going there as a visitor and sort of renting something, it just doesn't feel right. It feels weird.
and some not so great, but mostly really good experiences. I tell you what I have found hard. I found it really hard going back to UK, because without my house, like I had this lovely home there for... I've always lived there. But going there as a visitor and sort of renting something, it just doesn't feel right. It feels weird.|||有些虽然不怎么样，但绝大多数都是非常棒的体验。我告诉你我觉得最难的是什么。我觉得回英国真的很难，因为没有了我自己的房子，我在那儿曾有过这样一个可爱的家……我一直住在那里。但作为访客去那里并租点东西住，感觉就是不对劲。感觉很诡异。
It's really disconcerting. I was just there for a couple of weeks to see my family, my parents. And I don't know. But equally I've learned, I quite like being a foreigner. I quite like being a foreigner in a city. It feels slightly less emotionally tiring. I don't know why.
It's really disconcerting. I was just there for a couple of weeks to see my family, my parents. And I don't know. But equally I've learned, I quite like being a foreigner. I quite like being a foreigner in a city. It feels slightly less emotionally tiring. I don't know why.|||这真的让人很不自在。我前不久在那儿待了几个星期，去看望我的家人、我的父母。我不知道。但同样地我学到的是，我挺喜欢当一个外国人的。我挺喜欢在一个城市里当一个外国人的。这在情感上感觉稍微不那么累人。我不知道为什么。
In the UK, you know, I read the news about the UK and I'm like, oh, not again. What are they doing? You know, I feel so emotionally, but it's like your uncle letting you down. You're like, oh, don't behave like that. Yeah, we don't have anything like that here. Whereas here, here I'm like, well, it's not my problem.
In the UK, you know, I read the news about the UK and I'm like, oh, not again. What are they doing? You know, I feel so emotionally, but it's like your uncle letting you down. You're like, oh, don't behave like that. Yeah, we don't have anything like that here. Whereas here, here I'm like, well, it's not my problem.|||在英国，你知道，我读到关于英国的新闻时，我就会想：哦，又来了。他们在搞什么鬼？你知道，我在情感上感觉如此，但这就好像你的叔叔让你失望了一样。你会想：哦，别那样表现。是的，我们这里可没有那种事。然而在这里，在这里我就会想：嗯，这又不是我的问题。
Yeah, that's nice. So when you go back and you're sitting with your parents at dinner, is there ever a time to reflect and go back like we're doing now about, hey, remember when you guys kind of lit the fuse in me with the theater and stuff? Like, things have worked out. A little bit. My mom's not so well.
Yeah, that's nice. So when you go back and you're sitting with your parents at dinner, is there ever a time to reflect and go back like we're doing now about, hey, remember when you guys kind of lit the fuse in me with the theater and stuff? Like, things have worked out. A little bit. My mom's not so well.|||是的，那挺好的。所以当你回去和父母坐在一起吃晚饭时，有没有那么一个时刻去反思并回顾过去，就像我们现在这样，比如：嘿，还记得你们当年怎么用戏剧之类的东西在我心中点燃火种的吗？看，现在一切都挺好的。有一点吧。我妈妈身体不太好。
The light in my mom is... I'm sorry. Or the spirit of my mom is slowly fading. She's happy and she's not in pain, but she's not who she... She was very much the lightning in our family. She was the kind of trailblazer. She was the one putting on these plays and packing up our crazy little French de cheveux car and saying, right, we're going to drive across France and camp and like she just was full of energy.
The light in my mom is... I's sorry. Or the spirit of my mom is slowly fading. She's happy and she's not in pain, but she's not who she... She was very much the lightning in our family. She was the kind of trailblazer. She was the one putting on these plays and packing up our crazy little French de cheveux car and saying, right, we're going to drive across France and camp and like she just was full of energy.|||我妈妈身上的光芒正在……我很抱歉。或者说我妈妈的精神正在慢慢消逝。她很开心，也没有痛苦，但她已经不是那个……她曾非常像我们家里的闪电。她是一个开路先锋般的人物。她是那个组织排演这些戏剧、收拾我们那辆疯狂的法国小破车然后说“好啦，我们要开车横穿法国去露营”的人，她身上仿佛总有使不完的能量。
And really, I think a big part of why I'm doing what I do and my sister does what she does. So I don't, I miss that with her. I certainly have that with my, my sister still and my dad. And that's fun. It's nice looking back at those. It's interesting, isn't it? The further away you get from that formative time, how you can reflect on what impact it was having on you and what direction it was sending you in, you know. We'll be right back.
And really, I think a big part of why I'm doing what I do and my sister does what she does. So I don't, I miss that with her. I certainly have that with my, my sister still and my dad. And that's fun. It's nice looking back at those. It's interesting, isn't it? The further away you get from that formative time, how you can reflect on what impact it was having on you and what direction it was sending you in, you know. We'll be right back.|||真的，我认为我之所以从事现在的工作以及我姐姐做她所做的事，很大一部分原因都来源于此。所以我很怀念她身上那种特质。我和我姐姐还有我爸爸之间依然有这种感觉。这很有趣。回想起这些感觉真好。这很有趣，不是吗？你离那个形成性格的成长期越远，你就越能反思它当时对你产生了什么影响、把你推向了什么方向，你知道的。我们马上回来。
And back to the show. And having done all the stuff that you've done and really proven any point you ever would have wanted to make or make people proud or yourself proud, I can't imagine that there's any box left unchecked, but you tell me, is there something if it came your way, you go, ah, yeah, that I have not yet done, or I've been avoiding, you know,
And back to the show. And having done all the stuff that you've done and really proven any point you ever would have wanted to make or make people proud or yourself proud, I can't imagine that there's any box left unchecked, but you tell me, is there something if it came your way, you go, ah, yeah, that I have not yet done, or I've been avoiding, you know,|||欢迎回到节目中。鉴于你做过的所有那些成就，并且真正证明了你想证明的任何观点，或者让人们为你骄傲、让自己为你骄傲，我无法想象还有什么标准是没有达到的，但你告诉我，是不是有什么事情如果降临到你头上，你会说：“啊，对，那是我还没做过的，或者是我一直在回避的，”你知道的，
is it a frickin' musical, is it a voice in an animated film, is it, I mean, you've just touched so many things. There are definitely filmmakers out there that I admire immensely and would really love to work with. And then, and there's the odd part. Yeah, but not sort of, I mean, there are roles in Shakespeare that I'd love to play one day on stage, but that's sort of not necessarily immediately.
is it a frickin' musical, is it a voice in an animated film, is it, I mean, you've just touched so many things. There are definitely filmmakers out there that I admire immensely and would really love to work with. And then, and there's the odd part. Yeah, but not sort of, I mean, there are roles in Shakespeare that I'd love to play one day on stage, but that's sort of not immediately.|||是该死的音乐剧吗？是动画片里的配音吗？是——我的意思是，你已经涉足了太多领域。外面绝对有许多我极其钦佩并且非常渴望合作的电影制作人。然后，还有一些奇怪的角色。是的，但并不是那种——我的意思是，莎士比亚戏剧里有些角色我幻想着有一天能在舞台上扮演，但这并不是迫在眉睫的事。
But honestly, something you and I talked about and something you're so good at encouraging, I've seen you do it with others, is directing. I mean, I love the idea of it, it scares the hell out of me. You make it look incredibly straightforward and easy, I don't know how you do that. I mean, watching you direct, lead that team out of the gates and perform in it was really quite remarkable, mate.
But honestly, something you and I talked about and something you're so good at encouraging, I've seen you do it with others, is directing. I mean, I love the idea of it, it scares the hell out of me. You make it look incredibly straightforward and easy, I don't know how you do that. I mean, watching you direct, lead that team out of the gates and perform in it was really quite remarkable, mate.|||但说实话，有一件事你和我谈过，而且你非常擅长鼓励别人——我见你对其他人做过这一点，那就是导演工作。我的意思是，我很喜欢这个想法，但它把我吓得半死。你把它表现得极其简单直白，我不知道你是怎么做到的。我的意思是，看你执导、带领那个团队惊艳开局并亲自参演，真的非常了不起，老兄。
And it kept making me think. Having a partner like you makes it easy, truly. It made me really look at it and consider again. You should have. It scares me because of the scale of the decisions. Is it one of those because you thought like, fuck, if this guy could do it, then anybody could? Exactly.
And it kept making me think. Having a partner like you makes it easy, truly. It made me really look at it and consider again. You should have. It scares me because of the scale of the decisions. Is it one of those because you thought like, fuck, if this guy could do it, then anybody could? Exactly.|||这让我一直在思考。有你这样的搭档让事情变得很简单，真的。这让我真正审视它并重新考虑。你早就该这样了。它让我害怕的是那些决策的规模。是不是因为你当时想：操，如果这家伙都能做到，那任何人都能做到？完全正确。
I get that, that makes sense. That's not as scary. If this simpleton, if this, no, I talk a little bit about it, because he is, and Jason is, and we are so proud of him, we love him dearly, and we're so proud of what he's been able to do. What it was like working with Jason as a director,
I get that, that makes sense. That's not as scary. If this simpleton, if this, no, I talk a little bit about it, because he is, and Jason is, and we are so proud of him, we love him dearly, and we're so proud of what he's been able to do. What it was like working with Jason as a director,|||我懂了，这说得通。那样就没那么可怕了。如果这个大笨蛋，如果这个——不，我稍微多聊聊这个，因为他就是，杰森就是，我们为他感到无比骄傲，我们深深地爱着他，我们为他所能取得的成就感到无比自豪。和作为导演的杰森合作是怎样一种体验，
talk a little bit about that, because we do talk about it, but we haven't had anybody on here, really, to talk about that experience. Okay, the mood. First, so talking to those who don't know. Talk about his explosion. Yeah, none. The explosion, yeah. This is the mood. So talking to those who don't know. Talk about his explosion. Yeah, none. The explosion, yeah.
talk a little bit about that, because we do talk about it, but we haven't had anybody on here, really, to talk about that experience. Okay, the mood. First, so talking to those who don't know. Talk about his explosion. Yeah, none. The explosion, yeah. This is the thing. You guys will know, the most important thing, I think, on a film set is the atmosphere, right?|||简单聊聊这个，因为我们确实讨论过，但我们这里还没有真正请谁来谈过那段经历。好的，气氛。首先，向那些不知道的人讲讲。讲讲他的爆发。是的，完全没有。所谓的爆发，对。这就是关键所在。大家都会知道，我认为在电影片场最重要的事情就是氛围，对吧？
This is the thing. You guys will know, the most important thing, I think, on a film set is the atmosphere, right? It's a massive team, all these different groups and skill sets doing all these different things, but they all want to be appreciated, they all want their time and they all need their time. And Jason's just a master at keeping that going.
It's a massive team, all these different groups and skill sets doing all these different things, but they all want to be appreciated, they all want their time and they all need their time. And Jason's just a master at keeping that going.|||这是一个庞大的团队，所有这些不同的组别和技能组合在做着各种不同的事情，但他们都希望得到赏识，他们都想要属于自己的时间，也都需要自己的时间。而杰森简直就是维持这种状态的大师。
And everyone, I mean, the spirit of this company, I've got to tell you, cast, crew, everyone, was so positive. I mean, that was demonstrated at the end. We had a wonderful wrap party. Everybody's there with their family. Everyone stays from like, you know, early doors to the close. I mean, it was so popular. Which is unusual. That's unusual.
And everyone, I mean, the spirit of this company, I've got to tell you, cast, crew, everyone, was so positive. I mean, that was demonstrated at the end. We had a wonderful wrap party. Everybody's there with their family. Everyone stays from like, you know, early doors to the close. I mean, it was so popular. Which is unusual. That's unusual.|||每个人，我的意思是，这个剧组的精神面貌——我得告诉你，演员、剧组人员、每一个人——都是如此积极向上。我的意思是，这一点在杀青时得到了证明。我们举办了一个精彩的杀青派对。每个人都带着家属出席。每个人都从，你知道的，开场一直留到结束。我的意思是，它太受欢迎了。这很不寻常。这太不寻常了。
Yeah, it is unusual. And that was led by him. And the style of the piece was set up by Jason because it was his, how he saw it, and he, like I said, led us out of the gates, he directed the first two, and so setting that up and getting that right and sort of, what's the word, ingraining it in the DNA of the piece.
Yeah, it is unusual. And that was led by him. And the style of the piece was set up by Jason because it was his, how he saw it, and he, like I said, led us out of the gates, he directed the first two, and so setting that up and getting that right and sort of, what's the word, ingraining it in the DNA of the piece.|||是的，这很不寻常。而这全是由他引领的。这部作品的风格是由杰森确定的，因为那是他的视角、他的看法，而且他，正如我所说，引领我们惊艳开局，他执导了前两集，所以确立这种风格、把事情做对，并且某种程度上将其——用哪个词来着——深深烙印在这部作品的基因里。
And then as an actor, right? And then he's also there as an actor playing opposite you, leading by example, but also, there are those moments where suddenly it's just those little tiny words of suggestion or little tiny nudges like, this is great, this is good, but why don't we go down this path, should we try this? And it's those moments where you feel like,
And then as an actor, right? And then he's also there as an actor playing opposite you, leading by example, but also, there are those moments where suddenly it's just those little tiny words of suggestion or little tiny nudges like, this is great, this is good, but why don't we go down this path, should we try this? And it's those moments where you feel like,|||然后作为一名演员，对吧？然后他同时又以演员身份和你对戏，以身作则，不仅如此，还总会有那么一些时刻，突然之间只是那么几句微小的建议或者小小的提示，比如：“这个很棒，这个很好，但我们为什么不走这条路呢？我们要不要试试这个？”正是那些时刻让你觉得，
oh, this is so much fun. This is like, you're kind of playing. And you're not, even if you're doing a really dramatic scene, you're kind of giggling to yourself, thinking like, oh, we're doing this. Like, you know. And our parents are out of town.
oh, this is so much fun. This is like, you're kind of playing. And you're not, even if you're doing a really dramatic scene, you're kind of giggling to yourself, thinking like, oh, we're doing this. Like, you know. And our parents are out of town.|||哦，这也太好玩了。这就好像，你其实是在玩耍。而且你不会——即使你在演一场非常戏剧化的戏，你也会忍不住暗自偷笑，心想：天哪，我们居然在搞这个。就像，你知道的。而且我们的父母都不在城里。
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And we're allowed to. We can keep going. Yeah, Jamie, do you have that a little bit of like, I can't believe I got the keys to the car here. Oh, every second of the day. And all the toys. Yeah, Jamie, do you have that a little bit of like, I can't believe I got the keys to the car here. Oh, every second of the day. And all the toys. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And we're allowed to. We can keep going. Yeah, Jamie, do you have that a little bit of like, I can't believe I got the keys to the car here. Oh, every second of the day. And all the toys. Yeah, Jamie, do you have that a little bit of like, I can't believe I got the keys to the car here. Oh, every second of the day. And all the toys. Yeah, exactly.|||是的。对，对，对。而且我们被允许这么做。我们可以继续。是的，杰米，你有没有那种“我真不敢相信我拿到了这辆车的车钥匙”的感觉？哦，无时无刻不在。还有所有的玩具。是的，杰米，你有没有那种“我真不敢相信我拿到了这辆车的车钥匙”的感觉？哦，无时无刻不在。还有所有的玩具。是的，完全如此。
And it was also sort of like, you got to be such a smarty pants when you're directing and be sort of serious and you got to think about every corner of the room. But then this character I was playing was such a dingbat, like a lovely sort of like just simpleton. And so happy to throw that switch in between like, okay, here we go, ready?
And it was also sort of like, you got to be such a smarty pants when you're directing and be sort of serious and you got to think about every corner of the room. But then this character I was playing was such a dingbat, like a lovely sort of like just simpleton. And so happy to throw that switch in between like, okay, here we go, ready?|||而且这也像是，当你当导演时，你得表现得像个万事通一样聪明，还得有点严肃，你必须考虑到房间的每一个角落。但随后我扮演的这个角色却是个十足的笨蛋，是一个可爱的、单纯的傻瓜。所以能在那两者之间自如切换真是太开心了，比如：“好吧，我们开始吧，准备好了吗？”
Yeah, okay, let's roll. And then I was sort of joking. I told Jude, I said, you know, the sort of the, what do you call it? The fix or the secret to going into my character. All I have to do is just separate my jaw. Because this guy's kind of a mouth breather. Yeah, I go from director to this character
Yeah, okay, let's roll. And then I was sort of joking. I told Jude, I said, you know, the sort of the, what do you call it? The fix or the secret to going into my character. All I have to do is just separate my jaw. Because this guy's kind of a mouth breather. Yeah, I go from director to this character|||好的，开拍。然后我开玩笑地跟裘德说，我说，你知道的，那种，怎么说呢？进入我这个角色的诀窍或秘密。我所需要做的就是把我的下巴松开。因为这家伙有点是用嘴呼吸的。是的，我从导演转换到这个角色，
by just separating my jaw. And we're ready to go. Here we go, let's roll. That's really funny. I will say, I will say before, you'd actually directed before, but I will say our experience of working on Arrested Development, Jason Jason was the ultimate team captain.
by just separating my jaw. And we're ready to go. Here we go, let's roll. That's really funny. I will say, I will say before, you'd actually directed before, but I will say our experience of working on Arrested Development, Jason Jason was the ultimate team captain.|||只需要把下巴松开就行了。我们就准备好开拍了。来吧，开拍。这太搞笑了。我得说，我得说之前，你其实已经当过导演了，但我必须说我们在《发展受阻》剧组合作的经历中，杰森·杰森绝对是终极团队队长。
And I also learned a lot about what it takes to be a captain. No, you should be doing it too. No, but what it takes to be a captain from that guy, it was potentially the only thing I learned because he has nothing else to teach. I can get you to 10. You can count to 10 if I can teach you.
And I also learned a lot about what it takes to be a captain. No, you should be doing it too. No, but what it takes to be a captain from that guy, it was potentially the only thing I learned because he has nothing else to teach. I can get you to 10. You can count to 10 if I can teach you.|||我也从那家伙身上学到了很多关于如何成为一名队长所需要具备的素质。不，你也应该去当导演。不，但是从那家伙身上学到如何成为一名队长，这可能是我学到的唯一的东西，因为他根本没什么别的东西可教了。我能带你数到10。如果我能教你的话，你也能数到10。
Well, okay. And what's your impression, Jude, just quickly thin slice of Sean. Take a look at him over there. I look like a thin slice. Thin sliced tag. Of white bread. I mean, be honest, be brutally honest. I like the idea, I'm going to join Sean in that bubble.
Well, okay. And what's your impression, Jude, just quickly thin slice of Sean. Take a look at him over there. I look like a thin slice. Thin sliced tag. Of white bread. I mean, be honest, be brutally honest. I like the idea, I'm going to join Sean in that bubble.|||好吧，好吧。那裘德，你对肖恩有什么印象？快速来个肖恩的“切片剖析”。看看他坐在那儿的样子。我看起来就像一片薄薄的切片。薄切的面包标签。白面包。我是说，说实话，极其诚实地说。我喜欢这个主意，我要加入肖恩的那个小圈子。
I like the idea of being pushed around. To zip him in. Yeah, let's just do it. He's just trying to keep his powder dry for the Star Wars section of the interview, which we can start now, Sean, if you're all set. Well, I want that, but I have one question before, I am ready to go on that.
I like the idea of being pushed around. To zip him in. Yeah, let's just do it. He's just trying to keep his powder dry for the Star Wars section of the interview, which we can start now, Sean, if you're all set. Well, I want that, but I have one question before, I am ready to go on that.|||我喜欢那种被人推来搡去的感觉。把他拉进拉链里。行吧，那就这么办。他只是想留着弹药应付采访中的《星球大战》环节，如果你准备好了的话，肖恩，我们现在就可以开始了。好吧，我很期待那个，但在那之前我有一个问题，我已经准备好谈那个了。
But one question before. Scotty slides in on his chair like so. And I have an update. Just like this. And it just sings. No, Jude, we touched on it before a little bit. I want to go back just for a second. That kind of air, that time when you're sitting between jobs and you're like, God, is touched on it before a little bit. I want to go back just for a second. That kind of, that time when you're sitting between jobs
But one question before. Scotty slides in on his chair like so. And I have an update. Just like this. And it just sings. No, Jude, we touched on it before a little bit. I want to go back just for a second. That kind of air, that time when you're sitting between jobs and you're like, God, is touched on it before a little bit. I want to go back just for a second. That kind of, that time when you're sitting between jobs|||但在那之前先问一个问题。斯科蒂像这样滑着椅子过来了。我有一个最新消息。就像这样。它简直棒极了。不，裘德，我们之前稍微聊到过这个。我想花一秒钟倒回一下。那种氛围，当你坐在两份工作之间无所事事，然后想：天哪，之前稍微聊到过这个。我想花一秒钟倒回一下。那种，当你处于两部戏之间的空档期时，
and you're like, God, is something going to come? And that uncertainty of what we do. When you were younger and you went through those, did you have other jobs? Is there any time where you're like, God, I should start thinking of something else to do with my life because I don't think anything's going to come.
and you're like, God, is something going to come? And that uncertainty of what we do. When you were younger and you went through those, did you have other jobs? Is there any time where you're like, God, I should start thinking of something else to do with my life because I don't think anything's going to come.|||然后你就会想：天哪，会有工作找上门来吗？以及我们这行的那种不确定性。当你年轻经历这些的时候，你做过其他工作吗？有没有那么一刻你想过：天哪，我得开始考虑换个别的事情来过我的人生了，因为我觉得不会再有工作找上门了。
And then talented Mr. Ripley comes, or whatever it is. Fortunately not. And I lived a pretty simple life early on. And then I became a father pretty young and that would be all consuming. So that I was always, I mean, there was always something to do. So fatherhood didn't scare you
And then talented Mr. Ripley comes, or whatever it is. Fortunately not. And I lived a pretty simple life early on. And then I became a father pretty young and that would be all consuming. So that I was always, I mean, there was always something to do. So fatherhood didn't scare you|||然后《天才雷普利》就来了，或者类似的机会。幸运的是没有。我早期的生活相当简单。然后我很年轻就当了父亲，那会占据我所有的精力。所以我总是——我的意思是，总有事情要做。所以为人父的责任并没有吓得你
into thinking about another occupation? Well, luckily- Like a more steady? it was never so much that I suddenly thought, and if it was, then I was usually saved by the life support of another job or a potential another job. But I realized in the last couple of years, it's been a really big shift for me with my company because suddenly, even if they're not coming to fruition, although we've had a pretty good run so in the last couple of years,
into thinking about another occupation? Well, luckily- Like a more steady? it was never so much that I suddenly thought, and if it was, then I was usually saved by the life support of another job or a potential another job. But I realized in the last couple of years, it's been a really big shift for me with my company because suddenly, even if they're not coming to fruition, although we've had a pretty good run so in the last couple of years,|||去考虑改行吗？嗯，幸运的是——比如找一份更稳定的工作？倒不是说我突然这么想，即使有这种想法，我通常也会被另一份工作或潜在工作的“生命维持系统”给救下来。但我意识到在过去的几年里，我的公司给我带来了一个非常巨大的转变，因为突然之间，即使它们没有最终实现——尽管我们在过去几年里发展得相当不错——
just having the sense that you've got your hands on the reins and you can develop stuff and you're communicating with writers and directors. This is Riff Raff with the great Ben Jackson. Great Ben Jackson who's been alongside me for like 22 years and the company has given me a much better sense of navigating those moments of thinking.
just having the sense that you've got your hands on the reins and you can develop stuff and you're communicating with writers and directors. This is Riff Raff with the great Ben Jackson. Great Ben Jackson who's been alongside me for like 22 years and the company has given me a much better sense of navigating those moments of thinking.|||只要拥有那种你已经握住了缰绳、你可以自主开发项目并且正在与编剧和导演沟通的感觉。这就是由伟大的本·杰克逊创立的Riff Raff公司。伟大的本·杰克逊陪伴了我大约22年，这家公司让我对如何度过那些思考的时刻有了好得多的掌控感。
Because ultimately, you're still an actor waiting for someone to think you're right for a part. But if you can cook your own food, that's a real privileged place to be, and you don't take it lightly, and you work really, really hard as a producer, as does he. Yeah, I love it.
Because ultimately, you're still an actor waiting for someone to think you're right for a part. But if you can cook your own food, that's a real privileged place to be, and you don't take it lightly, and you work really, really hard as a producer, as does he. Yeah, I love it.|||因为归根结底，你依然是一个在等待别人觉得你适合某个角色的演员。但如果你能自己做饭（自给自足），那就是一个真正享有特权的处境，你不会把它当成理所当然，而且作为制片人，你工作非常非常努力，他也是如此。是的，我很喜欢这样。
I like the process of, I love finding ideas. I love introducing writers to directors and seeing that kind of blossom and bloom. And that is a sign I love it. That's the way it happened with Order, right? Didn't you contact Justin Curzell for this? That's right, that's right. What was that conversation like?
I like the process of, I love finding ideas. I love introducing writers to directors and seeing that kind of blossom and bloom. And that is a sign I love it. That's the way it happened with Order, right? Didn't you contact Justin Curzell for this? That's right, that's right. What was that conversation like?|||我喜欢这个过程，我喜欢寻找创意。我喜欢把编剧介绍给导演，并看着这种合作开花结果。这正是我热爱它的标志。拍《秩序》的时候不就是这样的吗？你不是为了这个联系了贾斯汀·库泽尔吗？没错，没错。那次对话是怎样的？
Did you know him before? No, not at all. You were just a fan of... A massive fan, and you know when you suddenly someone, and it's never me, I'm really good at chiming in having an opinion, but I'm never someone, I'm never very good with a blank page. You know when people go, okay let's discuss the directors.
Did you know him before? No, not at all. You were just a fan of... A massive fan, and you know when you suddenly someone, and it's never me, I'm really good at chiming in having an opinion, but I'm never someone, I'm never very good with a blank page. You know when people go, okay let's discuss the directors.|||你以前认识他吗？不，完全不认识。你只是——的粉丝？一个超级粉丝，而且你知道当突然有人——从来都不是我，我很擅长插话发表意见，但我从来都不是那种人，我面对空白的一页时从来都不太在行。你知道当人们说：“好吧，我们来讨论一下导演人选”时。
I always go, uh... Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And you know, you can't be, I want to be smart, the smart one who goes, I've got a left of field idea. I'm always like, you go first, and then I'm really strong to go, no, no, no, not them, not them, not them. But someone mentioned Justin, I think it was Zach, or it could have been Brian.
I always go, uh... Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And you know, you can't be, I want to be smart, the smart one who goes, I've got a left of field idea. I'm always like, you go first, and then I'm really strong to go, no, no, no, not them, not them, not them. But someone mentioned Justin, I think it was Zach, or it could have been Brian.|||我总是会说：“呃……”对，对，对，对。你知道的，你不能——我想表现得聪明一点，做那个说“我有一个剑走偏锋的想法”的聪明人。我通常都是说“你先说”，然后我就会态度坚决地否定：不，不，不，不是他们，不是他们，不是他们。但有人提到了贾斯汀，我想是扎克，或者可能是布莱恩。
Zach Bailyn. Zach Bailyn, a wonderful writer who we worked together on Black Rabbit. And it just was one of those, oh yes, this is a perfect fit. This guy makes, this guy looks at really dark areas and kind of toxic people, but puts them in a world where you, you start, it's not about empathizing with them, but you understand them and he makes it kind of safe
Zach Bailyn. Zach Bailyn, a wonderful writer who we worked together on Black Rabbit. And it just was one of those, oh yes, this is a perfect fit. This guy makes, this guy looks at really dark areas and kind of toxic people, but puts them in a world where you, you start, it's not about empathizing with them, but you understand them and he makes it kind of safe|||扎克·贝林。扎克·贝林，一位优秀的编剧，我们曾在《黑兔》中合作过。这简直就是那种“哦，是的，这绝配”的感觉。这家伙创作的——这家伙着眼于非常黑暗的领域和某种有毒的人，但把他们置于这样一个世界中：你，你开始——这并不是要对他们感同身受，而是你理解了他们，而且他让你能以一种相对安全的方式
for you to go into their worlds. And then he also operates on this high energy. He's a big guy and he loves capturing the energy of scenes and drama and he was just the perfect fit. So yeah, we had, it was, we zoomed with him. He was in his house in Tasmania with his big beard and it looked literally like his hair all blown. It looked like he'd just come off a, you know,
for you to go into their worlds. And then he also operates on this high energy. He's a big guy and he loves capturing the energy of scenes and drama and he was just the perfect fit. So yeah, we had, it was, we zoomed with him. He was in his house in Tasmania with his big beard and it looked literally like his hair all blown. It looked like he'd just come off a, you know,|||去走进他们的世界。而且他工作时能量极高。他个头很大，热爱捕捉场景和戏剧的能量，他简直是完美的人选。所以，是的，我们和他进行了视频通话。他当时在塔斯马尼亚的家里，留着大胡子，看起来简直就像头发被风吹乱了一样。看起来就像他刚刚结束了——你知道的，
hauled in a whale and kind of come in, come in and sat there like this and just blew us away with his insight. Like, yeah, I think I can do this. Yeah. And then when we were looking to get a director for the finale of Black Rabbit, Zach and Jude and Zach's partner, Kate, they suggested Justin Crezel. And I was like, are you fucking kidding?
hauled in a whale and kind of come in, come in and sat there like this and just blew us away with his insight. Like, yeah, I think I can do this. Yeah. And then when we were looking to get a director for the finale of Black Rabbit, Zach and Jude and Zach's partner, Kate, they suggested Justin Crezel. And I was like, are you fucking kidding?|||捕完一头鲸鱼然后走进来，走进屋里就这样坐着，用他的见解彻底震撼了我们。就像是：“是的，我想我能搞定这个。”是的。然后，当我们寻找《黑兔》大结局的导演时，扎克、裘德还有扎克的合伙人凯特，他们建议找贾斯汀·库泽尔。我当时就想：你们特么在开玩笑吧？
We're not going to get Justin Crezel to direct the finale of this thing? And they're like, are you fucking kidding? We're not gonna get Justin Curzell to direct the finale of this thing? And they're like, no, no, no, we can ask him. What do you mean you can ask? How do you know him? Well, we just finished a movie with him. Come on, you guys just did a movie? So I had no idea that they had just worked with Justin
We're not going to get Justin Crezel to direct the finale of this thing? And they're like, are you fucking kidding? We're not gonna get Justin Curzell to direct the finale of this thing? And they're like, no, no, no, we can ask him. What do you mean you can ask? How do you know him? Well, we just finished a movie with him. Come on, you guys just did a movie? So I had no idea that they had just worked with Justin|||我们难道能请到贾斯汀·库泽尔来执导这部剧的结局吗？他们却说：你们特么在开玩笑吧？我们怎么就不能请贾斯汀·库泽尔来执导这部剧的结局呢？他们说：不，不，不，我们可以去问问他。什么叫你可以去问？你怎么认识他的？我们刚和他合作完一部电影。拜托，你们刚拍完一部电影？所以我根本不知道他们刚刚和贾斯汀合作过，
and thank God it went well because they reached out and asked him and he- He answered the phone. He said, yeah. And was the reaction from the crew when he came to, was there like, now we got a director on set. Now we can get going. Exactly.
and thank God it went well because they reached out and asked him and he- He answered the phone. He said, yeah. And was the reaction from the crew when he came to, was there like, now we got a director on set. Now we can get going. Exactly.|||谢天谢地一切顺利，因为他们联系了他并向他发出邀请，然后他——他接了电话。他说行。当他来到片场时，剧组的反应是不是像：“现在片场来导演了，我们终于可以开干了。”正是如此。
I saw that. There was a lot of relief. We just teed that up. I know, I know, I know. But by the way, if I don't do it, if I didn't say that, Jason would call me after and say, are you okay? Like, are you sick?
I saw that. There was a lot of relief. We just teed that up. I know, I know, I know. But by the way, if I don't do it, if I didn't say that, Jason would call me after and say, are you okay? Like, are you sick?|||我看到了。大家都松了一口气。我们刚才只是在做铺垫。我知道，我知道，我知道。但顺便说一句，如果我不这么做，如果我不这么说，杰森事后就会打电话问我：“你没事吧？”比如，“你生病了吗？”
You were a little slow. You were slow. A little under the weather. Let's talk about Star Wars. Yes, Andor, Acolyte, where does Star Wars skeleton crew come in the line? I mean, it's absolutely standalone. Oh, it is.
You were a little slow. You were slow. A little under the weather. Let's talk about Star Wars. Yes, Andor, Acolyte, where does Star Wars skeleton crew come in the line? I mean, it's absolutely standalone. Oh, it is.|||你刚才有点慢半拍。你反应有点迟钝。有点身体不舒服。我们来聊聊《星球大战》吧。是的，《安多》《守夜人》（应为《阿科莱特》/《侍者》），《星球大战：骨干船队》在时间线上排在哪里？我的意思是，它完全是独立的。哦，是的。
I like that. Yeah, I mean, it fits in, I think it's around the same time as The Mandalorian, but here's what got me. I was six, seven when the first film came out. And I was thinking about this the other day. I mean, I don't remember going, I maybe saw The Rescuers or 101 Dalmatians. And then Star Wars.
I like that. Yeah, I mean, it fits in, I think it's around the same time as The Mandalorian, but here's what got me. I was six, seven when the first film came out. And I was thinking about this the other day. I mean, I don't remember going, I maybe saw The Rescuers or 101 Dalmatians. And then Star Wars.|||我喜欢这样。是的，我的意思是，它融入其中，我认为它的时间设定大约和《曼达洛人》同期，但真正打动我的是这个。第一部电影上映时我六、七岁。我前几天还在想这事。我的意思是，我不记得自己去过——我可能看过《救难小英雄》或者《101斑点狗》。然后就是《星球大战》。
And so to me, that was cinema. I was like, holy cow, what the hell is this? And not only that, for the next five years, it was what I played. I was living it. I was running around my yard going pew pew, right? I'm on, you know, I'm Vader. Still am.
And so to me, that was cinema. I was like, holy cow, what the hell is this? And not only that, for the next five years, it was what I played. I was living it. I was running around my yard going pew pew, right? I'm on, you know, I'm Vader. Still am.|||所以对当时的局来说，那就是电影。我当时想：天哪，这到底是什么鬼？不仅如此，在接下来的五年里，这就是我玩的游戏。我全身心沉浸其中。我在院子里跑来跑去，嘴里配着“pew pew”的激光枪声，对吧？我扮演的是，你知道的，我是维达。现在依然是。
And you know, so it was formative. And John Watts just had this awesome idea. He called me and said, so look, you know, what if we, all that awe and wonder and dazzle that we had as kids, what if we put the kids in that world? So it's taking goonies, it's taking normal kids, you kind of argue and they don't get on with their parents
And you know, so it was formative. And John Watts just had this awesome idea. He called me and said, so look, you know, what if we, all that awe and wonder and dazzle that we had as kids, what if we put the kids in that world? So it's taking goonies, it's taking normal kids, you kind of argue and they don't get on with their parents|||你知道的，所以这对我的性格形成起到了决定性作用。乔恩·沃茨当时有个绝妙的主意。他打电话给我说：听着，你知道的，如果我们把当年我们还是孩子时感受到的那种敬畏、惊叹和耀眼光芒，如果我们把孩子们放进那个世界里会怎么样？所以这有点像借鉴《七宝奇谋》，让普通的正常孩子们——你们会争吵，他们和父母合不来，
or they don't get on with each other or they don't like school. They run away, they get lost and they're in that world. Yeah, that's cool, that's cool, that's really cool. I was just like, this is a great idea. Yeah, I love that. If you enjoyed that style of work with the sort of the volume stages, the green screen.
or they don't get on with each other or they don't like school. They run away, they get lost and they're in that world. Yeah, that's cool, that's cool, that's really cool. I was just like, this is a great idea. Yeah, I love that. If you enjoyed that style of work with the sort of the volume stages, the green screen.|||或者他们彼此合不来，或者他们讨厌学校。他们离家出走，迷路了，然后就身处那个世界之中。是的，这太酷了，太酷了，真的太酷了。我当时就想：这主意太棒了。是的，我很喜欢。如果你喜欢那种带有虚拟摄影棚（Volume stages）、绿幕的工作风格。
It was all volume, luckily, yeah. I mean, I think had it been all green, I don't know that I would've enjoyed it as much. I've done that before. The volume is really wonderful. I mean, it's super. Really? For Tracy, I don't know that I would've enjoyed it as much. I've done that before. The volume is really wonderful. I mean, it's super... Really? For Tracy, this is a stage that's basically...
It was all volume, luckily, yeah. I mean, I think had it been all green, I don't know that I would've enjoyed it as much. I've done that before. The volume is really wonderful. I mean, it's super. Really? For Tracy, this is a stage that's basically...|||幸运的是，全部都是用虚拟摄影棚拍的，是的。我的意思是，如果全都是绿幕的话，我不知道自己是不是还会这么享受。我以前拍过那种。虚拟摄影棚真的太棒了。我的意思是，超级棒。真的吗？对崔西来说，这是一个基本上……
Every wall is like a big movie screen. So, you're kind of living... With high definition. Yeah, you're living in an atmosphere. So, they put the flooring in. So, say you're on a moon, the floor is dust and sand and rocks and boulders, but it goes right up to the volume screen and then the perspective of the screen just carries on, so you can be standing
Every wall is like a big movie screen. So, you're kind of living... With high definition. Yeah, you're living in an atmosphere. So, they put the flooring in. So, say you're on a moon, the floor is dust and sand and rocks and boulders, but it goes right up to the volume screen and then the perspective of the screen just carries on, so you can be standing|||每一面墙都像是一个巨大的电影屏幕。所以，你有点像生活在……高清晰度之中。是的，你生活在一种氛围里。所以，他们铺好了地板。打个比方，假设你在一个月球上，地面是尘土、沙子、岩石和巨石，但它一直延伸到虚拟屏幕，然后屏幕上的透视效果就会自然延续下去，所以你可以站在
in a desert that disappears for hundreds of miles with ships flying around you, and with a wind blowing, right, they use a wind machine, so you're on, for all intents and purposes, you're on that moon. And so it's not just for the viewer, too. As an actor, when you're performing, you're actually seeing that. You're experiencing that as well. Yeah, that's really cool.
在一个方圆数百英里、周围飞驰着飞船、狂风呼啸的沙漠里，对吧，他们用了风力机，所以实际上，基本上，你就在那颗卫星上了。所以这不仅对观众如此。作为一名演员，当你表演时，你真的能看到那个场景。你也在亲身体验。是的，这真的很酷。
And the same goes for then a more cluttered set, like a market, we had this huge space port and they built all the bars and the stalls and what have you. And each avenue looks like it just goes on and on and on and on and you've got creatures crossing over, and of course, what you've really only got is, I'd say, 50 foot of that, and then the rest is just all on these huge screens. Yeah, that's really cool.
杂乱一些的场景也是一样，比如市场，我们当时有个巨大的太空港，他们建了所有的酒吧、摊位之类的地方。每条街看起来都仿佛无休止地延伸下去，还有各种生物穿梭其中，当然，实际上你真正拥有的场景大概只有50英尺长，剩下的全都是靠那些巨大的屏幕呈现的。对，这真的很酷。
I want to go back to a question about... Sean, you could do one where you could have your dad, like, he's there. You want to be on the screen. I don't think there's screens big enough. And you can have it so that he's not leaving, he's standing. You can just look at the screen and pause. He's not leaving your family. Wait, before we get out of the skeleton crew world
我想回到刚才那个关于……肖恩，你可以做这样一个设定，让你的爸爸，就好像他在那里一样。你想出现在屏幕上。我觉得没有那么大的屏幕。你可以让他不用离开，就站在那儿。你只要看着屏幕然后暂停就行了。他没有离开你的家庭。等等，在我们离开“骷髅船员”的世界之前
to talk about, who else is in that with you? Because I think I read somebody that I know is in that with you. Who else is in it? Kerry Condon and Tunde from TV on the radio. And then there are the four kids. I know that guy. Gino Tunde. He's a lovely guy. I met him a couple times, really cool,
聊聊看，还有谁和你一起出演？因为我好像读到过某个我认识的人也参演了。还有谁在里面？凯瑞·康顿和来自TV on the Radio乐队的通德。然后还有那四个孩子。我认识那家伙。吉诺·通德。他是个很好的人。我见过他几次，真的很酷，
big fan of TV on the radio. Yeah, me too. And his interesting piece of trivia. He was great in Rachel Got Married, remember he was in that? That's right, that's right, Demi, Demi film. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
TV on the Radio的超级粉丝。对，我也是。他有一个很有趣的冷知识。他在《蕾切尔的婚礼》里演得很棒，还记得他演过那个吗？没错，没错，德米，德米的电影。对，对。对，对。
Did they play all the music live in that? I think they did. Did they really? In real time. I think that was the idea on that film, that when did. Did they really? In real time. Wow. I think that was the idea on that film. Because remember they're in a band and they're all playing at the wedding. I love the way that film looked. Do you remember the color of that film?
那部电影里的音乐全是现场演奏的吗？我想是的。真的吗？实时的。我想那部电影的初衷就是这样，当……真的吗？实时演奏。哇。我想那部电影的初衷就是这样。因为记得他们在组乐队，而且他们都在婚礼上演奏。我喜欢那部电影的视觉风格。你还记得那部电影的色调吗？
Yeah. The Ted Demme or Jonathan Demme? Oh, good question. Jonathan. Both. Jude, when you named all those... Nick Frost. Is Nick Frost in it? Nick Frost is the voice of a droid. Oh, I love Nick Frost.
对。是特德·德米还是乔纳森·德米？哦，好问题。乔纳森。两个都是。裘德，当你念出那些……尼克·弗罗斯特。尼克·弗罗斯特在里面吗？尼克·弗罗斯特是一个机器人的配音。哦，我爱尼克·弗罗斯特。
Nick Frost is one of my favorite, sorry Sean, he's one of my favorite. No, I love Nick Frost. I love Nick, he's so. Me too. Fucking, we all know, he's so fucking funny. Yeah, he is funny. Anyway.
尼克·弗罗斯特是我最喜欢的，抱歉肖恩，他是我最喜欢的……不，我爱尼克·弗罗斯特。我爱尼克，他太……我也是。他妈的，我们都知道，他太他妈搞笑了。对，他是挺搞笑的。总之。
When you were going, Jude, when you were talking about going from city to city to, you know, in the last few years, just going, all those cities you named. Is it hard to keep a schedule for eating properly, working out, taking care of yourself with the time differences and then living in a trailer and then coming back to a hotel?
当你在说的时候，裘德，当你在说过去几年里一个城市接一个城市地奔波时，你列举了那么多城市。由于时差，还要住在拖车里然后又回到酒店，要保持规律的饮食、锻炼和照顾好自己，这很难吗？
It seems like so, it's like to me, it seems so disruptive and a gorgeous life because we're all doing what we love to do, but how do you maintain a good schedule for yourself? Allow a lot of time when I land somewhere to get over jet lag. I'm not one of those people who can just pick straight up and get, give me a couple of days.
听起来好像……对我和来说，这似乎既具颠覆性又是一种美妙的生活，因为我们都在做自己热爱的事，但你究竟是如何为自己保持一个好作息的呢？我落地某个地方后会留出很多时间来倒时差。我不是那种能立刻振作起来的人，给我留几天时间。
Because I think jet lag really is like an illness. You've got to kind of love yourself and go. It's like you've got flu, just go to bed. But you've also then, yeah, once you're out of that, I enjoy, I really like keeping fit, so I train quite hard every day, usually before I go to work, so whatever that time is, I usually go do something for an hour.
因为我觉得时差真像是一场病。你必须得善待自己，对自己说，这就跟得了流感一样，上床睡觉吧。但同时呢，对，一旦你缓过劲来，我很享受，我真的很喜欢保持健康，所以我每天训练得挺刻苦的，通常是在我开始工作前，所以无论那是几点，我通常都会去花一个小时做点运动。
And then I usually take my own food. So I can eat when I really want. I can't be doing on a set, where they're like, lunch! And you're like, it's 5 p.m. We're talking, like, what was I meant to, I got to eat at the right time. So I eat, like, I get up and I eat in the morning, I make sure I've got food so when it's midday or one,
然后我通常会自己带食物。这样我能在真正想吃的时候吃。我可受不了在片场，他们突然喊：“吃午饭了！”而你却觉得，现在才下午5点。我们在聊天呢，这算什么，我得在正确的时间吃东西。所以我吃东西很有规律，比如我早上起床就吃，确保自己备好了食物，这样到了中午或一点时，
I eat my lunch. Are you particular about your food? Like, do you eat quite healthily, et cetera? Yeah, I'll eat anything, but I kind of get, I can feel myself getting a bit slower and stodgier if I don't eat well. Yeah. But I'm not, I'm, I am, kind of got a funny relationship.
我就能吃午饭了。你对食物很挑剔吗？比如，你吃得比较健康之类的吗？对，我什么都吃，但如果我吃得不好，我能感觉到自己变慢、变沉重了。对。但我不是那种……我跟食物的关系有点微妙。
Like, I really love a good restaurant, I love good food, but equally, it's just fuel. I like lamb, You like lamb? I love lamb. Lamb chops? Yes. Hang on a second. Hey man, we're not doing non sequiturs
比如，我真的很喜欢好的餐厅，我喜欢美食，但同样地，它也只是燃料。我喜欢羊肉。你喜欢羊肉？我喜欢羊肉。羊排？是的。等一下。嘿，老兄，我们现在可不是在说
at a left field right now. Yeah. I love lamb. You know what? I had lamb last night. I want lamb chops. I had lamb last night. Wait, they're at the house?
那种毫无关联的突发话题。对。我喜欢羊肉。你知道吗？我昨晚吃了羊肉。我想吃羊排。我昨晚吃了羊肉。等等，它们是在家里？
Or did you go to a restaurant, Willie? No, I had lamb at home here, yeah. And you know what I was really upset about? Was it a lamb shank? It was, they were lamb chops and I didn't have any, somehow there was no mint jelly or mint sauce around. Oh, you see, my wife loves the mint jelly. I'm not fussed about it.
还是你去了餐馆，威利？不，我是在这里的家里吃的羊肉，对。你知道我最沮丧的是什么吗？那是羊腿吗？不是，那是羊排，而我没有……不知怎么的周围居然没有薄荷果冻或薄荷酱。哦，你看，我太太超爱薄荷果冻。我对这个倒不在意。
As long as it's got a little seasoning on it. Yeah. I really need it. You know, Jude, we, honestly, I don't know about you guys, I mean, we could just keep this going forever, probably. I know. You were, Jason, you were so right. He's, we're going to save this for the wrap up, but he has something else.
只要上面有一点调味就行。对，我真的很需要这个。你知道吗，裘德，说实话，我不知道你们怎么想，我的意思是，我们大概可以把这个一直聊下去。我知道。杰森，你太对了。他……我们留到最后总结时再说，但他还有别的事。
Jude, what an absolute delight we have kept you waiting. No, for me too. Oh, God. I'm so happy you did this. We'll do it again when Black Rabbit comes on in about a year. Yes, we got it. And I just, I'm crazy about you, love you. I'm going to talk to you.
裘德，我们让你久等了，你真是太好了。不，我也一样。哦，天哪。我很高兴你上了这个节目。等“黑兔”大约一年后上映时，我们再录一次。没问题，说定了。我真的太喜欢你了，爱你。我要跟你通话。
I'm actually going to call you right after the end of this because I need to ask a question about something. But thank you, buddy, for doing this. Enjoy the rest of your press trip. Stay rested and get back to the family and enjoy the winter. Yeah. It's what a joy and so lovely to see the three of you. Like this has been a joy.
其实我在这结束后马上就会给你打电话，因为我有事要问。不过谢谢你，老兄百忙之中抽出时间。享受你剩下的宣传行程吧。好好休息，回去陪家人，享受冬天。太好了，能看到你们三个真是太开心了。这次交流太棒了。
Thank you. It's good to see you, Jude. Great luck with the order. Everybody go see the order. It's so damn good. Go see anything that Jude's in. Go see it, go watch it, go streaming, go see it. Jude, you are a gentleman.
谢谢。很高兴见到你，裘德。祝《秩序》大获成功。大家都去看《秩序》。它真的太棒了。去看任何裘德出演的作品吧。去电影院看，去看流媒体。裘德，你真是一位绅士。
Thank you, sir. Take care. Thank you, buddy. Goodbye. Bye. Bye. Do I do, buddy. Let's wish you, yeah. Bye. Bye. Do I do that? He did it, he did it. He's fantastic.
谢谢你，先生。保重。谢谢你，老兄。再见。再见。再见。我要说吗，老兄。让我们祝你，对。再见。再见。我是这么做的吗？他做到了，他做到了。他太棒了。
So guys, I'm telling you, this guy, if you think he's great on a podcast or a Zoom call, try going in the trenches with him for eight months. It's just a great- You always talked about how much joy you had with him. Yeah, you really did. And you, and it was unsolicited, like you would just be like, God, that's your law. While you were making it from every stage of it,
所以伙计们，我告诉你们，这家伙，如果你觉得他在播客或Zoom通话里表现得很棒，那试着跟他并肩作战八个月看看。这简直是一段伟大……你总是说跟他合作有多么快乐。对，你真的这么说。而且你是主动说的，比如你经常会说，天哪，这是你的法律。你在创作它的每一个阶段，
you're like, God, this guy is great. God, you know, blah, blah, blah, blah. Like you were just, and you meant it. Yeah, he's one of the best partners ever. I'll tell you, one of the other ones was, was a guy we mentioned was Matt Damon. Did that little bit on air. And I mean, just the level of experience
你都会说，天哪，这家伙太棒了。天哪，你知道的，吧啦吧啦吧啦。就好像你是由衷而发的，你是认真的。对，他是史上最好的搭档之一。我跟你说，另一个搭档就是我们提到过的一个家伙，马特·达蒙。在节目里提过那一小段。我的意思是，这些人身上的经验
and professionalism with these guys is just not to be undervalued. On a group level. Also probably comes from gratitude too. We all know what it's like not to work and then when you get, when you're lucky enough to be in a position. Yeah, they definitely appreciate where they're at.
和专业精神是绝对不容低估的。从整体层面来看。这也可能源于感恩吧。我们都知道没工作是什么滋味，然后当你得到机会，当你足够幸运能处在那个位置上……对，他们真的很珍惜自己现在的处境。
Super kind. J.B., have you ever seen that, Gattaca? I did, but I don't remember it, which is not uncommon. Sean, you've seen it, right? I can't believe I've never seen it. Sean? I know, I'm gonna watch it.
超级友善。J.B.，你你看过那部《千钧一发》吗？看过，但我记不清了，这倒也不罕见。肖恩，你看过吧，对吧？我不敢相信我竟然没看过。肖恩？我知道，我要去看。
I really urge people, and again, I don't wanna, I've waxed on a lot, but that film is really a remarkable film, and it's really good. And Jude is so, it's hard to imagine that it's one of the first things he did because he's so excellent in it. He's one of those actors, never sucks. Never ever, you're exactly right, Jamie.
我真的极力推荐大家，再说一次，我不想……我已经唠叨很多了，但那部电影确实是一部杰出的电影，而且真的很好。而且裘德是那么……很难想象这是他早期作品之一，因为他在里面太优秀了。他是那种从不演砸的演员。永远不会，你太对了，杰米。
He's in the John Goodman school. He never, ever sucks, never. Actors who know kind of what their goal posts are and have the discipline to not, or the overindulgence to step outside of that. Like he finds a version of himself in every character that he does and yet he never plays anything safe.
他是约翰·古德曼那个门派的。他从不、从不演砸，绝不。有些演员清楚自己的底线在哪里，并且有自律性不去逾矩，或者说不会过度放纵自己去跨出那个界限。就像他在他演的每一个角色里都能找到自己的一部分，然而他从不走任何安全路线。
So, you know, it's just. Pretty cool. Thank you for bringing him on. Yeah, I was so happy to be able to have him because obviously he should have been your guest, but I was happy to. Well, I wanted him a long time ago before you guys started working together.
所以，你知道的，这真的很酷。谢谢你把他请来。对，我很高兴能邀请到他，因为显然他本来应该是你的嘉宾，但我也很高兴能……其实我很早就想请他了，在你们开始合作之前。
Oh really? Yeah, yeah. So I wanted him a long time ago, and then it just sort of, this is when it happened. I'm glad that we made it through the entire interview without talking about fucking Robert Downey, you know what I mean? Oh, that guy.
哦，真的吗？对，对。所以我很早就想请他了，然后事情就顺理成章地……这次终于成了。我很高兴我们完成了整个采访，却没有聊到他妈的小罗伯特·唐尼，你知道我的意思吗？哦，那个家伙。
About Sherlock, because Downey has gotten so much fucking free air. I'm so mad at Downey. Why? You know what I mean, about Sherlock. Because Downey has gotten so much fucking free air. I'm so mad at Downey. Why? Because why? Just in general, just because. Just success, the success. His success, and I know he's very deserving of it,
关于《福尔摩斯》，因为唐尼获得了太多他妈的曝光机会了。我生唐尼的气。为什么？你知道我的意思，关于《福尔摩斯》。因为唐尼获得了太多他妈的曝光机会了。我生唐尼的气。为什么？因为为什么？没为什么，就凭这个。因为成功，成功。他的成功，我知道他完全当得起，
blah, blah, but I'm just kind of, you know. Let's have a counterpoint. Where do you think he's over indexing? Opinions. He's, he'll just, he'll call me, you want to talk about FaceTime, you always are. He faced, Danny FaceTimes in a way like it's so out of the blue.
吧啦吧啦的，但我就是有点……我们来个对立观点吧。你觉得他在哪些方面过度曝光了？各种意见。他，他会直接打电话给我，你想聊FaceTime对吧，你总是这样。他用FaceTime打过来时总是那么突如其来。
Uninvited FaceTimes. And then he's in the bath and he'll go, you know, I was thinking what you should do. And I'm like, fucking what, man? Yeah, towel off and just call me or write me. Yeah. I do love him. I do love him to death though, I will say. He's doing a big play, go see his play.
不请自来的FaceTime。然后他在泡澡，还会说，你知道的，我在想你应该怎么做。我心想，他妈的你在说什么啊，老兄？对，擦干身子再给我打电话或发信息吧。对。不过我确实爱他。我爱他爱得要命，我得这么说。他在演一部大型话剧，去看看他的剧吧。
Go see McNeil with our good friend Robert Downey. I think it's probably closed by now. What depends when this airs? Oh yeah, it depends on what it airs. Lincoln Center. But I tell you what never closes is Jude Law's talent. I'm so good. That is always open.
去看麦克尼尔，和我们的大好朋友小罗伯特·唐尼一起。我猜现在大概已经演完了吧？这得看这期节目什么时候播出？哦对，这取决于播出的时间。林肯中心。但我告诉你，永远不会谢幕的是裘德·洛的天赋。我太厉害了。那可是永远营业的。
Always open 24-7. Think about, Jay you said, and Sean you named it, think about all the different films that he's, when I was thinking about. But you're not even touching his theater. This guy has been on Broadway with like Othello or Hamlet or Macbeth, there are probably all three of them.
全年无休24小时营业。想想看，正如杰你所说，肖恩你也列举了，想想他演过的所有不同电影，当我想到……但你根本还没提到他的舞台剧。这家伙曾在百老汇演过《奥赛罗》、《哈姆雷特》或《麦克白》，可能这三部他都演过。
I think he got a Tony nomination for one of those. Or maybe one. I mean, he's just done, we did not mention the Sherlock Holmes films, which were major hits. Road to Perdition, you ever seen that? Incredible. Yeah, so good, I love the movie. Cold Mountain, he got an Academy Award nomination for,
我想他凭其中一部获得过托尼奖提名。或者说其中一部。我的意思是，他演过太多，我们甚至没提到《大侦探福尔摩斯》系列电影，那可是票房大热。还有《毁灭之路》，你看过那部吗？难以置信。对，太棒了，我喜欢那部电影。《冷山》，他因此获得了奥斯卡奖提名，
that was amazing. AI, he was in that film AI back in, Yeah, I love that. Like 20 years ago. Yeah. Enemy at the Gates, you ever seen that film? Enemy at the Gates where he plays, I think he plays like a sniper in Stalingrad,
那太棒了。人工智能，他参演了那部电影《人工智能》，就在……对，我喜欢那部。大概20年前吧。对。《兵临城下》，你看过那部电影吗？《兵临城下》，他在里面扮演……我记得他演的是个斯大林格勒的狙击手，
is that the one? Oh wow, really? No, I haven't seen that one. Oh dude. I'm up for all the same parts all the time. You are. Three callbacks. You, I haven't seen that one. Oh, dude. I'm up for all the same parts, all the time. You are. Three callbacks. You've been up for them.
是那部吗？哦哇，真的吗？不，我没看过那部。哦，老兄。我一直在为所有相同的角色试镜。你确实是。三次试镜回调。你，我没看过那部。哦，老兄。我一直在为所有相同的角色试镜。你确实是。三次试镜回调。你一直都在为它们试镜。
Yeah. Yeah. The animated version of each of these. No, have you? Sniper, real snipers, yeah. Really? Yeah, Sniper City. One's called Sniper City, the other one's called Sniper.
对。对。这些角色的动画版本。不，你试过吗？狙击手，真正的狙击手，对。真的吗？对，狙击城。一个叫《狙击城》，另一个叫《狙击手》。
Sniper City. Sniper, it's one, another one's called Sniper, I didn't even know her. Wow. Yeah. You know what? I haven't heard of it, I wonder who all those are out. Those are out now I wonder who they were written
《狙击城》。《狙击手》，是部电影，另一个叫《狙击手》，我甚至都不认识她。哇。对。你知道吗？我没听说过，不知道这些都是谁写出来的。这些都已经上映了，不知道它们是谁
by Say bye Jason SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbico and Michael Granteri. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
写的。跟杰森说再见。“SmartLess”由罗布·阿姆格维、贝内特·巴尔比科和迈克尔·格兰特里100%有机纯手工打造。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。